thought experiments in physics are
pivotal for the generation of novel
ideas
the dissolution of old ones or simply
for an original take on specific
phenomenons that already exist
given that fundamental physics has been
stalled in the past few decades
primarily due to a lack of data as well
as other factors
and i'm trying to put forth my own
theory of everything and integrate it
with consciousness
i thought how far can i go with thought
experiments
james robert brown is a professor of
philosophy
specif specializing in the philosophy of
mathematics and physics
at the university of toronto and he was
generous enough to give me
a few hours of his time he's written
several books which i recommend you
check out
and we spoke yesterday which is what
you'll see first as well as at the end
i'm going to append a sliver of a
conversation that me and him had about
two years ago
but i never posted this is perhaps the
deepest dive you'll see on youtube on
thought experiments as well as platonism
there's even a test to see whether or
not you're a platonist or non-platonist
or newtonian or leibnizian
and they're in the timestamps again in
these podcasts i tend to not shy away
from technical details
for one because i think when you
sacrifice details it's akin to
sacrificing the truth
or at worst giving a false impression as
well as i think that the audience that
is you
are extremely smart and you can keep up
enjoy
it's as if this is my first time alright
man
hello professor brown how's it going
it's going well
uh and please call me jim okay jim
so jim what are you working on these
days i'm working on
the connection between mathematics and
ethics
there's uh some features of both that
are already well known
for instance our mathematical knowledge
and our ethical knowledge
don't come from sensory experience
like yeah do you mind expounding uh well
by sensory experience i just mean
sight hearing smell taste um
you don't know that uh there are
infinitely many prime numbers because
you've gone out and seen them right
you don't know that root two is an
irrational number because you held up a
ruler
on a diagonal square and got an
irrational number
um our mathematical knowledge is
definitely not
empirical though it might be connected
to the empirical world in
some indirect ways but it's certainly
not like the
natural sciences at all well what does
that have to do with ethics
well ethics is exactly the same so
you could see one person kill another
person
that could be an empirical experience
but to judge it as an immoral act is not
empirical
somebody pulls out a gun and shoots
somebody else and a red light doesn't
flash in the corner of your eye saying
this was wicked this was wicked
okay and how we uh
acquire ethical knowledge and how we
acquire mathematical knowledge are
surprisingly similar in a number of ways
you mentioned before in one of your
talks on youtube about the distinction
between thick and thin concepts
do you mind delineating that for the
audience oh
not at all and this is a really
interesting idea it's
fairly new inside ethics
so the idea of thin concepts are
thin concepts can be anywhere they can
be in the sciences in everyday life
and in ethics so if i say the house is
on fire
i'm using thin concepts if i say
words like mass color taste
those are all sin concepts
but they're from the factual realm
okay and then in the uh ethical
or uh evaluative realm are more thin
concepts but they're just in a different
realm so
good bad beautiful ugly
um uh obligation those
duty those are thin concepts from ethics
okay so the world it seems like is made
up of thin concepts some are in the
factual realm
some are in the normative evaluative
ethical realm
now then um a few years ago people began
to
focus on a number of words that we use
in daily life and they seem to be really
important in
in how we treat things and how we reason
and these these words are called thick
and that's because they're
simultaneously um
fact type terms and
the evaluative terms okay so if i say
if i say curd you are very healthy
that's actually i'm saying two things
i'm talking about your
health in a factual sense like your
blood pressure is 120 over 80.
all right for instance but i'm saying
more than that when i say you're healthy
i'm saying and it's a good state that
you're in
so there's an evaluative component as
well as a factual component
when i say you're healthy another
example beside
okay yeah i'll give you lots more um
brave courageous
okay courageous uh if i say mary
was courageous that's it that
includes a kind of factual
component especially if we've just seen
mary
run into a burning house and and save
the family's pet dog
okay so she's pulled it out so there's a
straightforward factual
component to that about mary's action
okay
but there's also an evaluative component
like what she did was a good thing
it's good to be brave well done mary
we're really proud of you
so brave is different it's thick
brave is thick now some people say
you don't need thick concepts they're
very convenient
so you don't need them because i could
say this mary ran into the house
she brought out the family dog
and here comes the evaluative
and what she did was good
or i can just sort of summarize it mary
was very brave
and the word brave courageous those sort
of terms
those are thick concepts and we use them
a lot
and we reason with them a lot um
something
is uh um and once you get that once you
get the feeling
um it's uh you can find them all over
the place why is
the word good not a thick concept uh
because it's it's
it's just thin it just it's just pure
evaluation it doesn't tell you anything
right right right okay uh it doesn't
tell you anything factual that's why
it's thin
evaluative and if i say mary entered the
burning house
that doesn't tell you anything uh
evaluative it just
gives you a factual description of
something that happened
okay but once you get the hang of it you
see all sorts of terms are thick
loyal liar
dastardly uh untrustworthy
see those if i say kirk you're very
untrustworthy
i'm suggesting that you've cheated me on
something or you've lied to other people
or something like that
and it's a bad thing okay so you see how
it's a thick
term right does it always go to good or
bad on that one
line spectrum no if you were if we were
in if we were in the artistic
realm uh it might be rather than good or
bad it might be beautiful ugly
something like that okay but you can see
the evaluative term
uh in the one in what from the one realm
and the
straightforward factual so if i describe
a picture like
well there's a little bit of red here
and there's some blue there
okay that's that's the sort of you just
read the rgb values
that's a thin yeah that's a thin
description of the painting
from a factual point of view and then if
i want to say it's spectacularly
beautiful
or it's charming sorry charming sorry
charming would be um
would be a thick concept it's beautiful
just plain beautiful
okay that would be a thin concept and if
i say it's charming it's evocative
uh and and suggesting a combination of
things that are both
factual and uh evaluated simultaneously
those are the thick ones okay so why am
i interested in that
because that's that's what i just told
you sort of right and how does that
relate to mathematics
exactly okay that's the important
question so i've been thinking about
um by the way thick concepts in ethics
that's commonplace okay and everyone in
ethics
knows about thick thin and then the
standard views about them
okay when when i was thinking about
ethics and math i'm looking for all
kinds of connections between ethics and
math
not just the one about neither of them
are empirical
okay our knowledge isn't empirical in
either case
what are the other connections well one
of them
might be a kind that might be an inside
math and physics
a kind of thick concept so i don't want
to talk about facts and values now
i'm just using this as an analogy so
there can be math
and there can be physics pure math
okay you understand pure math is just
you know nothing but set theory
and pure physics has got nothing
mathematical about it
and the way uh math gets applied is math
provides models
for the physical realm this my what i
just said
is slightly contentious it's probably a
majority opinion
but there are lots of people who would
dispute it let's just stick with the
majority opinion for now
um math provides models of the world and
what a physicist will do
is look at the the range of models
in plato's heaven and say i think this
one
is is structurally very similar to the
physical realm
okay right and we apply math in that
sort of way
now uh that would be thin
pure math is just thin those are nothing
but thin concepts
pure physics without any math in it
nothing but pure
physical concepts could there be a thick
concept that's that that's that somehow
or other involves both not just modeling
modeling
is by itself isn't going to do it a
thick concept would be
a kind of really intimate uh
intertwining of the two and i was sort
of vaguely thinking about this and i
came across um
a wonderful quote in a famous calculus
book
book for any mathematicians who are
watching they'll know the book it's by
spivak
it's just called calculus uh did you
take physics in
math yeah do you know that you know the
book i'm talking about yeah it's a
famous book it's first year
one five seven one five seven ah okay
but it's a wonderful it's a wonderful
and his second book is also great it's
like a direct book where it's
tiny yeah book is large and then the
second book on manifold
yeah yeah yeah you're right you're
absolutely like two pages long
it takes you a whole semester to get
through that well one page of exposition
followed by ten pages of uh
uh gut wrenching problems that
are so hard to solve okay so anyway uh
there was this wonderful passage
in the calculus book so he's just doing
elementary stuff
he's teaching derivatives first
derivative
second derivative and he says all of
this stuff is really important
especially the second derivative y well
think about
newton's newton's law f equals m
a acceleration is the second derivative
okay we got that then he says
next time you're in a car and you go
around a corner
you can feel the second derivative
you think about that no no
i feel the acceleration right
and it's modeled i don't feel the second
you're gonna come on i don't feel a
second derivative don't be ridiculous
nobody can feel a second derivative it
exists in plato's heaven
you can't you can't smell an infinite
series
you can't taste the tangent plane and
you can't
yield the second derivative right that's
what that's what you should say
and i and i but the more i thought about
it i thought i wonder i wonder i wonder
if
if people who work with
well with math in general physicists and
engineers in particular
who maybe have to do problems of motion
where acceleration is important and they
get so
used to treating physical acceleration
think of
the acceleration as an actual physical
process
and attaching it to the second
derivative to calculate
it's become so internalized with them
that acceleration and second derivative
becomes a single concept
it's just a fused concept this would
this would be an example
of a thick concept and i got talking to
some physicist friends uh about this
and they're now they don't exactly
understand
and appreciate what i'm trying to get at
but there's enough of
an understanding that they could sort of
they could sort of agree that that some
parts of math not all
but some parts of math that they use
they've so internalized
that to utter the math or to other under
the
math less physical description
um they're just they're just uh so
intertwined it's become one single thing
what else besides acceleration is there
for math
well this would be hard this because i i
don't want to say it's all the time
because i i wouldn't want to say
that someone in quantum mechanics who
thinks about the state of the system
just flips over to a hilbert space which
is how we represent
states in quantum mechanics and just
think of them interchangeably
it's a possible candidate because we do
use the same notation for both we just
use a simple psi function for
the vector in a hilbert space or for the
state meaning
the physical property of a quantum
mechanical system that's a candidate but
i'm
i'd be reluctant to say that stick maybe
uh an example is a very old example a
good example
and that's real numbers and points on a
line
so you know you you have a line just say
the unit interval right and we just
attach all the
real numbers between zero and one okay
and we think of a real number and a
point as
the same thing just just back and forth
and once you it's it's well it's the
it's the whole basis of analytic
geometry
ever since ever since descartes said it
was uh
400 years ago when he just said real
numbers and
points on a line or pairs of numbers and
points in in the plane and so on
we just that they're just completely
interchangeable right
and you're saying that that's a thick
concept because i think i think maybe
word line
implies a space not line let's say point
point and number point and number they
become
um almost a single concept now we can
separate them okay i can ask you to
separate
in your mind and you can do that but
they're so interchangeable
in fact they're so interchangeable that
um girdle in a famous
article called what is cantor's
continuum hypothesis
starts out he says the continuum
hypothesis is the question
um how many real numbers are there or
equivalently how many points are there
on a line it just takes them to be
the same issue and that's that's
surprising
for a logician who is you know super
super careful
about um about making distinctions when
he thinks it's appropriate
okay so what's the significance of this
why are you spending your time thinking
about this
the i think it's intrinsically
interesting but
uh for me it can it might actually do
some work
um uh you know you know the continuum
hypothesis
this is the the claim that um
the first uncountable infinity is um
aleph one and it might be and it then
the claim is
that it is um the real numbers the real
numbers have size
out of one the natural numbers
are it's infinitely many but there's
only aleph
zero of them the real numbers are
a bigger infinity and the conjecture
is that um they're the the next biggest
infinity so they'd be
out of one no one's been able to prove
the continuum hypothesis uh or refute it
and in fact uh there are um
there's an independence proof meaning
you can't prove it and you can't refute
it on the basis of
existing axioms of set theory
right and if you think if you think that
the existing axioms of set theory are
adequate for the whole of mathematics
what that really means is the continuum
hypothesis is independent of all of
mathematics
right right now you can know everything
in math you still don't wouldn't know
the continuum hypothesis
so it's you could you could just
arbitrarily make it a
a new axiom that would solve the problem
but it would be very unsatisfying
because
right because why are you doing that
rather than making its negation
the new axiom so we're looking around
for um what you might call independent
evidence
for the continuum hypothesis one way or
the other
what might work well maybe physical
analogies would work you know you just
sort of think about it you're not going
to prove it you're not going to have
any old-fashioned proof but you might
have some other kind of argument
if you are a realist or a mathematical
platonist
you're going to say it is true
or it is false i just don't know which
okay now question how much detail do you
want
oh that's fine let's go in more i know
girdle was a platoonist and he believed
it's either
yeah i think that he proved that it's i
don't recall if it's
both either the negation or the positive
application of the continuity
he showed that it's consistent it's
consistent with the rest of set theory
yeah you can add it and you won't get
into trouble right and it was later
cohen
showed that you can add the negation and
you won't get into trouble
and that and the two results together
give you independence
the audience will keep up get into as
much detail as you like let's go into a
dis proof of the continuum hypothesis
okay you'll have to be hand wavy because
we don't have papers and pens
that's right powerpoint slides and this
is a this is a result um
uh a number of years ago from chris
freiling
uh an american logician and it's in
it's it's wonderfully clever and it's a
refutation of the continuum hypothesis
okay so um as you say
it'll be a bit hand wavy
so for for those with a math education
um they will know what uh oh i'm going
to start out with
what's called zermelo frankel set theory
including the axiom of choice
okay now with the axiom of choice
we can prove what's known as the well
ordering
theorem which means that you take any
set whatsoever
and you can give it a well ordering
and that's to and that means you can
line it up with the ordinal numbers
so one two three four five and then
omega
which is now the first uh infinite
ordinal
and then you keep counting ordinal's
ordinal ordinals and then when you get
all of the countable ordinary done you
get into the uncountable ordinals
this is this is this this will sound
like
um mystical nonsense unless you've
taken a course in sec theory and learned
about the hierarchy of infinite sets
so anyway the ordering theorem says
you can put any set including the real
numbers
between 0 and 1 you can line them up
with the this infinite string of
ordinals now they won't go in the same
order
as the the natural less than order
they'll be jumping all over the place
you know like one half might be
associated it's not an intuitive
ordering it's not like we
we have any apprehension of it no uh
here i'm just guarantees it
yeah the the well ordering theorem
guarantees that
that it exists but nobody has any idea
of what a well ordering of the real
numbers would be
no one's found one yet we've got well
orderings
of the rational and they're pretty
straightforward
but not of the real numbers
um so technically the well ordering
theorem says that the subset
that any subset is well ordered it says
that any subset has a first element
right right right uh just to see that
the ordinary ordering
is not a well ordering if i say take all
the real numbers greater than one half
sorry can you repeat that just to say
that what take
the real numbers yep greater than one
half
what's the first element right right
right greater than
not including one half doesn't have yeah
that's right uh it doesn't have a first
element so
that's just not a well ordering but with
some other bizarre ordering i might
take them uh any subset and and it would
have to have a well or
uh there'd have to be a first element
okay so we've we we imagine
that we've got a well ordering of the
real
numbers but just between zero and one
that'll do
okay now comes a little statistical
argument
you and i are gonna throw darts we're
gonna throw
darts at the real line between zero and
one
it's a thought experiment can't do it in
reality
but i thought it's better i throw a dart
and i get a number
p somewhere between zero and one you
throw your dart and you get a number q
also on the line between zero and one
now i'm going to make the following
argument um
your uh your
dart hit the number q which is going to
be
later in the well ordering than my dart
p
why because there's only
um a countable infinity at most
of numbers earlier in the well ordering
from p and an uncountable infinity
after and so so that you you might be
earlier than me but the probability is
zero
right right right and you your dart
you you've hit number q and you can say
exactly the same argument
you're going to say the chance that i'm
earlier in the well ordering is zero
and the chance that it's later is is one
now we've got an absurdity
because i've i've said you've got to be
later than me right
right right right and you've argued
correctly that i've got to be later than
you
right now i have different points yeah
and
and we've now we've just got an
absurdity and why
what led to this absurdity the
assumption that there are aleph
one real numbers if there were alice ii
it wouldn't be a problem
why why is that because uh we i might
have landed in
an uncountable there might be an
uncountable number of points earlier
than me
and an uncountable earlier than you so
we couldn't argue
we wouldn't be able to do that the trick
is
when you've got a countable infinity of
numbers
and here comes the result from what's
known as measure theory
the the pro it's it the chance of
landing in there
is zero it's not impossible but it's
zero probability
right and that's interesting for people
to wrap their head around that you can
have
a zero probability but possible that's
right
it's not very well people said that it's
not the same as impossible
okay um if that if
if anyone just to take a slight tangent
anyone who finds that absurd
think of a roulette wheel with uh
every real number between zero and one
on it okay you spin the wheel
and it's going to stop somewhere what's
the what's the chance it's going to land
on say
one half well
there's infinitely many places that
could stop
so the chance is one out of infinity
which is
going to be zero it can happen
but it's going to be zero probability
okay so you and i now have
uh this little we've each got this
little argument
and um um and we each show
that the the other guy is is
uh impossible and this is absurd
and the assumption the background
assumption that led to this
that the continuum hypothesis is true
is in trouble you've got to throw it out
okay
all right now
this is really interesting i mean it's
it could be an argument uh
you know that settles a continuum
hypothesis though it's not a proof in
any ordinary mathematical sense
it's really different mathematicians who
look at this are
oh they're very queasy you know they
don't like this kind of reasoning
they don't mind suggestive reasoning
that's outside of mathematics
they don't want to take it as real
evidence that that you know
that this could be a theorem you know a
real a real genuine
sure to be true result very uneasy about
it
and i'm uneasy about it i'm also curious
as how it works
i mean i know how i i can reproduce the
proof i know how it works in that sense
but why the hell does it work you know
it shouldn't work
and then what is its connection to
reality how is it that we can think this
and it's true
is that what you mean by no yeah yeah
yeah that's that's sort of
that's that's behind it all uh for sure
but in particular there are assumptions
made
for this little argument to go and
here that here here are here are some of
the assumptions first of all the real
numbers and the points on the line
correspond
okay so the geometric line between 0 and
1
and the uncountable infinity
uh between zero and one real numbers
they're
they're exactly the same they pair up ah
yeah okay
um it's an obvious assumption to make
given the long history of analytic
geometry
but i just want to make sure it's there
second thing when you threw a dart and i
threw a dart
each each of us hits a point at random
um the chance of hitting any point along
the line
is is no different than any other point
okay
it's equi-probability for every point
okay
my that's true for my dart also true for
your day
there's a symmetry between our throws
in the sense that it doesn't matter if
you throw first and i throw second
or i throw first and you throw a second
or if we throw simultaneously
it's irrelevant and finally uh
independence
the your result has no effect on my
result
vice versa okay now when you think of
all of those assumptions these are
crucial assumptions
um things like probability
uh can be captured completely inside set
theory
independence can be captured in
completely inside set theory
um the symmetry of the two ethos can be
captured completely inside symmetry
how come the damn argument works because
if i
if i try to spell out the probability
of my little argument or the symmetry or
the independence i tried to spell it out
in standard mathematics
and could get that result then
then then something would have gone
terribly wrong
i can't get that result from ordinary
mathematics
so the probability in my
argument the independence in the
argument
the symmetry in the argument can't be
the probability symmetry and
independence of standard mathematics
something else something weird is going
on it's it must be a related but a
different concept
in each case what do you think is going
on i think it's a thick concept
i think probability as we normally use
it is a thin
concept thin mathematical concept
i think in the dart thought experiment
to refute the continuing hypothesis i
think probability has taken on
a new richness
in the example it's become
physicalized in some sense
and so here's where i'm looking at the
analogy with ethics
instead of a thin concept from
mathematics
or a thin concept from physics i've got
a thick
this is thick probability it's got both
physical
and mathematical aspects to it like
like courageous is both in set theory we
can
formalize probability yep so what's
what's thick about this just the just
throwing the dart but we can
not use the dart and say we pick a point
at random
and there's obviously random variables
and which have nothing to do with darts
so what's what's thick i i don't hear
what's thick
about this i don't know maybe i'm thick
you gotta help no no not at all the the
thickness
the thickness would come in in the way
the thought experiment is done you're
supposed to imagine yourself throwing a
a dart at an actual line try to
try to make it physical even if you
think it's mathematical it's outside of
set theory
why do you have to imagine that why
can't you just say pick a point
at random instead of throwing a dart is
there a difference
well the dart the dart is is supposed to
be a guarantee that it's genuinely at
random
um if i asked you to pick a real number
between zero
and one at random i'm almost certain you
couldn't do it
um i know i know what i'm saying is that
you can formalize
what it means to pick a number from zero
to one randomly
in statistics independent of saying
throw a dart
and you can formalize it with set theory
you know
um yeah yeah yeah that's true that's
certainly true
uh the thing is well here's what here's
what i'm i am faced with
and you're faced with uh if we assume
that the argument works
the frightening argument works as a
refutation we assume it works
and and um and it does seem to make
these crucial assumptions
well it assumes mello frankel said three
with choice
okay and and then it assumes the the
randomness of the dark throw
the the symmetry of the dark throw the
independence of the dark throne
and the correspondence between real
numbers and points on a line
it assumes that if that if all of that
is just
part of mathematics existing mathematics
then we would have derived a refutation
of the continuum hypothesis inside
that's
right right right and that's all right
wouldn't have been independent after all
right since it is independent
demonstrably independent
one of those premises has to be false i
think i think
and so uh if i just say well let's take
the randomness one
i don't know which one is false at least
one of them has got to be false
so the randomness one is fault there
must be
um the randomness that we're assuming in
the thought experiment cannot be
analyzed in normal set theory terms
it's got to have some kind of physical
component that enriches it so that we
can pull off this argument
so that's where this is where the thick
concepts come i see
so it's it becomes not ordinary
randomness
in in standard math it's becomes a thick
randomness it's got a physical
it's become physicalized in some
important sense now you say physicalized
with a grimace
is that because there is you're a
platonist and you feel like
well if it's not a thinned mathematical
by the way is there
is there a connection between thin and
thick and platinism and
non-platonism i don't know um
most of the people who talk about thick
and thin
uh in ethics what they are
um they often conclude uh that this is
the end of the fact value distinction
so if you think of facts as part of the
physical realm and if you were a
platonist about ethics
and and they're declaring the end of
this dichotomy between
moral reality and physical reality
um then i'm not sure about the status of
moral reality when it's all over
i would like to think it's still there
and these are
a kind of hybrid um human made
concepts in both in ethics and in math
supposed to say that you would like to
believe that morals are a part
of of the platonistic world or a moral
oh definitely
yeah yeah i'm a moral realist yeah for
me there's um
i hate the i hate the distinction
between fact and value
because it makes it sound like values
aren't
themselves facts but they are they're
moral facts uh murder is uh
is wrong that's a moral fact setting
kittens on fire for pleasure to watch
them burn
and suffer that's it's a moral fact that
that's
uh wrong how how do we get to
how do we get that moral fact where does
that moral fact come from
okay now this is this is this gets back
to the the problem
a simultaneous problem for both ethics
and for mathematics
so uh most platonists believe not only
in the reality of mathematics
and if you're a platonist about ethics
or a moral realist you believe in
objective moral
facts the the big problem and the thing
that
people who are empiricists and
naturalists complain about is
you have no access to these facts
even if they did exist because you can
see smell
touch and so on but if these live in a
realm completely
separate from us you have no contact
with them you couldn't learn about them
and so on and so on the response from
uh moral realists platonus
um is to appeal to um intuition
an intuition is a cognitive capacity
that we have that will give us
knowledge so to take math
we have everybody has you know scads of
moral intuitions about math
even if you had almost no mathematical
training you have a powerful intuition
that two plus two equals four
and that's a moral intuition sorry no a
mathematical intuition
uh that two plus two equals four and if
i pressed you and i said
oh look i just read in the newspaper
today that
you know in in brazil
some wonderful physicists in brazil have
just
done some fine-tuned measurements and
they have discovered that
two plus two actually equals three point
nine five it doesn't equal four after
all
right this is actually we're just giving
me germain because there was a recent
controversy about two plus two equals
five i don't know if you've heard of it
no okay so
no no no the other side was being
serious it was
it was because they were saying that the
way that math is set up is
western and it's not taking into account
other modes of knowing and there are
possible worlds where two plus two could
equal five and in different
interpretations
which it's true i mean if you have
modulo something i'm sure you can make
two plus two equal five
or you round oh no you're gonna have
modular you're absolutely right
but it doesn't mean may be some
interpretation and there's probably good
rules of thumb
in in some sciences where you you're now
not talking
two plus two you're talking about two
somethings and two some things
so if you're talking about what is it
water a liter of water mixed with a
liter of alcohol
perhaps doesn't give you two liters of
liquid it gives you something like 1.9
liters of liquid because of the you know
the some atomic goings-on
reduces the the volume of the whole
thing
you could you might conveniently talk
that way yeah because you're in the lab
and it's very constrained
but no two plus two equals four and more
generally
you know a little bit of arithmetic and
then i can become abstract and i can say
um any number m and any number
n if i add them together m
plus n it's going to equal n plus
m and everybody they think about that
for a minute and a half and say yeah
yeah
right i see it yes it's true and it has
to be true
that's an example of a mathematical
intuition okay
okay okay it's not empirical though um
math and ethics have been the two thorns
in the side of empiricism
okay um just for a second because i'm
trying to wrap my head around this when
you have n
plus when you have like a plus b equals
b plus a just so that it's clear for
do we not define that with the addition
being commutative
like you and then we make a model and
say that our numbers correspond to it
we we we do but um uh
people's elementary experience with
arithmetic would lead them
in that very direction okay they've done
enough adding that they've been making
change they've been counting pebbles
who knows what um and after a while they
come to realize that whether they've
been told
that the community okay you're strictly
speaking about the intuition behind it
not
proving it to be true that's right uh
because to the audience to be true
that's really interesting
we actually assume it in in the way that
we define addition and multiplication
that they're
doing arithmetic in any formal sense
we typically start out with something
known as the piano axioms
okay and they tell us how to add how to
multiply
and they give us a principle called
mathematical induction
and then everything in arithmetic
follows
well i need to qualify that almost
everything in arithmetic follows
there is a problem about completeness
but never mind that
um and everybody's intuition if you've
been playing with arithmetic
for a while you'd say yeah this is the
truth this is how
addition works this is how
multiplication works okay let's not get
hung up on it let's assume
that okay that's an interesting strong
intuition those are examples of
intuitions
now uh we have the same thing in ethics
so um um if you saw
somebody if you saw some teenage kids
catch a kitten
pour gasoline on it set it on fire you
would be aghast you would be morally
outraged
um you have a very strong moral
intuition that that was an evil thing to
do but those kids don't
uh they might they might and they're
just uh overwhelmed by
peer pressure and gang behavior and
stuff like that
and then you're right they might not
even yeah unless i imagine they might
now let's take the edge case the which
the edge cases just to investigate this
so what if they genuinely don't have
anything wrong with that like genghis
khan for example said
the best of life would be conquering his
enemies and enslaving their women and
now we look at that
and say that that's ridiculous but let's
believe him that that actually
invoked pleasure in him and he thought
that was morally
correct okay okay i don't know
i don't know enough about him to know
exactly what's going on
so i'll give you the short answer and
that is we've made a hell of a lot of
moral progress
since since that announcement right how
do we
make how do we make the claim that we've
made moral progress without already
assuming what we're trying to prove
that's a very difficult that's an
extremely difficult question
um i don't want to say well
my views have won over the long run
um though they have like my view is we
shouldn't have slavery
and almost everybody agrees with that
now my view is that women
should be treated equally with men and
most people agree with that now that
they wouldn't have a century ago
my view is that um um gays and lesbians
and
and so on should be treated with uh you
know equal rights and dignity
and so on and so on and i'd say
uh at least a strong majority of
canadians if not a strong majority of
the world population
agree with that so um
i i don't have a hard and fast
non-circular argument
i can say that as people think about
these things over time
they tend to change their views in the
direction
that that we have come not many people
were
against slavery for years and years and
then had an epiphany and said
i made a terrible mistake i think we
should have slaves i think that would be
a great idea
okay people don't go in that direction
let me let me press for a bit i actually
agree with you but here's what i'm
thinking here's what pops into my head
so social consensus what is required and
what if
10 years from now you know there's some
evidence that people who are on the
lower end of the iq spectrum have more
children let's just imagine that many
people and we can even demean them and
say conservatives
like let's say we're let's imagine that
we're supporters that's we're aggressive
liberals
i'm not even i'm not saying we are but
let's see okay these foolish reactionary
conservatives are the ones that populate
the earth and then they like its slavery
later and the majority of the earth like
slavery except those who are enslaved
but they're a minority
does that make that correct no
okay no no no no so what's the reason
okay so there's two questions um is
there such a thing as objective right or
wrong
yes i mean correct is there is there is
there an objective
shape of the earth yes
i think it's round it's spherical
and i think we've got a ton of evidence
that this is so
but if for some reason in the future
people said no
we're pretty sure it's flat um
and then i would say well i pity that
future civilization they've got it wrong
they've made a terrible mistake that's
fact
straight factual stuff okay morally if
people actually said well i
we think we think slavery is a pretty
good idea
um i'd say no you're i would say they've
made a terrible terrible mistake
but um i acknowledge the possibility
that it could happen
germany was a very germany is a very
progressive country uh in the
you know uh 19th and very early 20th
century
and then by the time you know horrible
calamities in
in the in the 30s hitler comes to power
and a majority of germans are willing to
go along with some pretty horrific views
uh-huh yeah they're just wrong they're
just wrong
okay we can talk about that another time
but
basically my argument was this well
first of all i want to make it clear to
the people who are watching that i don't
think low iq people are conservative
i was just straw manny for the sake of
argument okay
second i thought that what you were
suggesting was given
that we have a line toward
something that over time people believe
in a certain value
that's evidence that the value is
objectively correct and then i was
saying well
what if that reverses or we go into
another direction and then you're saying
no that's wrong
but how does that not jive with saying
that there's societal movement towards a
certain direction and that
corresponds to being objectively correct
morally no no it's
this is this is a very good question and
it's very hard to answer
i don't have a terrific answer i only
have a weak answer
and my weak answer is that um it's like
science
we we make progress in science um
it's possible that what we believe today
about let's say quantum mechanics and
relativity
a hundred years from now people will say
ah
i don't know let's go back to newton
let's believe
newton okay i think i think the chances
of that
are minuscule and the thing is that
there's been
incremental evidence it's fallible
evidence
but incremental evidence all along
pushes people
upwards okay it makes us brighter we
know more we're more sophisticated
in physics and i think something like
that
goes on in our moral and political lives
too
interesting okay now with regards to
newtonian physics becoming
relativity and then okay we say that one
is more correct because it can explain
more
so it's just that's a planet that's
evidence
is pure explanatory power what makes the
theory correct
and the reason why i say that is oh okay
no
explanatory power is a sign is evidence
that it's correct
okay um it is it this is this much is
logically possible
for anyone who's a realist that
all the evidence could point away from
the truth
everything that we count as evidence
like is it explanatory powerful
yeah um does it um
is it incredibly accurate you know does
it make
spectacular predictions to the 25th
decimal place
yeah might do that too and it might and
yet in spite of all of this it might be
false what are your views on free will
by the way
do you believe in it yes leave against
it oh
interesting okay now are you like daniel
dennett where you say well i have a
compatibilist view
no i i have here i i i i
i feel completely at sea i speculate
away
i operate i i live my life as if i have
free will
i am i eat too much and i blame myself
i blame my willpower and uh while it
would be very nice to blame something
else
i can't i just blame myself i
i get angry at others i get angry
i mean some people i think can't help
what they believe others i think have
gone out of their way to make themselves
stupid and i blame them for that
so i'm i'm happy to blame people for not
doing what i think they ought to do
and i do think they have free will i
don't know how to live in a world
where we really don't have free will but
i may have i may be just
highly that's not an argument for free
will
that's just an argument for we have to
live as if
as if there is free will um i don't know
how
uh really to live otherwise now i've
seen some people who are very
sophisticated
you know talk about this subject and
maybe they'll be able to persuade me in
the long run
that we don't have free will or there's
a very good chance we don't have any
free will
but we should we can act like this and
this and this and this and
so on so i i i really
i i i have childish immature
underdeveloped views about pretty well
the standard
view that's opposed to free will is well
what caused you to make so-and-so
decision and then it's your neurology
okay well what caused that and you keep
going until you get to a cause that's
not you
yeah along that chain of causes right
right where does that chain of
reductionism because we just talked
about physics being
extremely powerful and more and more
accurate and there doesn't seem to be
room for free will so where does free
will
comport with our view of physics in the
way that it's formalized currently
no it's terrible um but it doesn't have
to be quite as crude as you just uh put
it
here's another issue in which i do not
have
strong views but it's sort of in the
background and this is the difference
between
this is the issue of reductionism and
emergence
so if you have a complete reductionist
view and your world is deterministic
it's very hard to make room for a free
will
but if you have an emergenciest view
that is
yeah physics is at the bottom but in a
certain level of complexity
there could emerge biological laws like
strong emergence
yeah and out of that could emerge uh
psychological laws
and so on and and free will would be
you know something that is emerging at
some higher level
it's not gonna it's not gonna it's not
gonna emerge out of elementary particle
physics
i mean sometimes people try to do that
because they take
quantum indeterminacy to to be uh you
know
this is stupid it's just really bad
arguments
um but if we did have some kind of
emergence you might have
you might have free will right but i
again i i can't make up my mind
okay yeah where i was gonna go is
there's no evidence for strong emergence
but there's plenty of evidence for
reductionism
like there's no link in the chain that's
broken
in the reductionist account as far as we
could tell
so then to believe that we have free
will i don't
i'm not suggesting that i don't believe
i'm just throwing something out so to
believe that we have free will
seems to be counter to evidence so how
do you jive
with saying that i'm a person who goes
wherever the evidence leads me
but simultaneously saying that i'm
someone who believes in free will and
when i say go wherever the evidence
believes
sorry that i'm a person i'm a person who
goes wherever the evidence leads
i mean evidence in terms of scientific
evidence because obviously you can be a
spiritualist and say well i have the
intuitions
you might appeal to intuitions but i'm
curious so what do you say to that
um well i'm i i i do
uh um i do count myself as somebody
who's led by the evidence
scientific on the other hand on the
other hand i'm not i don't agree with
you about
um we it's uh there's no gaps in the
going from us to elementary particles i
mean
try to imagine
um accounting for donald trump's
election
in terms of writing down the schrodinger
equation for the population of the world
what i meant and then solving it and
getting out
donald trump what i meant was that so
far there's no link that's been shown
to be false that doesn't mean that there
is no no i i i i completely agree with
you so there's no evidence for anyway
and there's plenty of women it's very
reliable that would be like religious
people who argue
for the god of the gaps god fills in the
gaps in
our scientific knowledge yeah it's a
foolish way of doing it let's talk about
platonism do you mind defining for the
audience what platonism is
sure um
modern platonism as opposed to being a
strict follower of plato
modern platonism is simply the view that
uh there are abstract entities
numbers being the most obvious um
example of this they have exist in some
way shape or form
yep they're real they exist um
and there are facts about them like two
plus two equals four
there are infinitely many prime numbers
and so on
and these uh objects
and these facts are completely
independent
from uh intelligent creatures so
even if no intelligent life existed
anywhere in the universe
it would still be true that there are
infinitely many prime numbers
if you believe that you're a platonist
in fact there's a little litmus test for
audience members who've never thought
about it before
ask yourself do you think mathematicians
discover
new truths of mathematics or do they
somehow invent or create them
shakespeare created hamlet
if shakespeare or no intelligent being
had ever existed
hamlet would not exist on the other hand
the spherical shape of the earth would
still be a fact
even if no intelligent being had ever
existed
i say math is more like the shape of the
earth
and less like hamlet that's what it is
a mathematical realist or a platonist
when you say
something that just popped into my head
was the infinite monkeys on the
typewriter and then you can
make it an algae between shakespeare and
information so just say the works of
shakespeare is just one extremely large
number given that you can
translate it to bits isomorphically okay
and that number
exists so then did shakespeare actually
invent
hamlet or did he discover it no no no
arithmetic is rich enough that it can
encode hamlet
that's all so so technically did he
discover it or did he create it
uh hamlet amlett was created by
shakespeare not discovered by
shakespeare
okay but when the mathematician
discovers uh
or produces when euclid produced the
theorem that there are infinitely many
prime numbers
euclid discovered something he
discovered something that
exists that is true independent from him
he didn't make it up
i see it's not a cultural item of any
sort it's
it's as it's just a group way the world
is
i see i see i see but it's the abstract
world it's not a physical object
it's an abstract entity yeah now what
creates this platonic world
it's always been there nothing created
it yeah so how do we talk about the
platonic world without sounding mystical
without sounding theological it's like
it's always there it's not it's it's
ever-present it is timeless
it's an uncaused cause yeah
well you can imagine you can imagine the
the universe the physical universe
always existing right
in fact there's a good there's good
reason to believe that it always has
i know we're we we're we talk about big
bang cosmology and we're
what 13.8 billion years old
but if but the inflationary scenario
we're probably just one of you know the
multiverse
and these things have been going on
forever so our mini our universe is just
one of a
infinite number of pocket universes
pocket universes have always existed
and they generate more um through
this process called eternal inflation
or just go back to pre-big bang
cosmology
where we used to believe standard
physics believed that the universe was
infinitely old it didn't have a
beginning
and it won't have an end it just is
eternal
not created by god this is atheists
we're happy to believe this
it's just this is the way things are so
the platonic world
was always there or even to say the word
always implies formulating it in terms
of time
and it's timeless this is a there's an
old philosophical distinction we hardly
use anymore
between eternal and semp eternal
uh eternal eternal semp eternal so e
sent eternal means true at all times
eternal means outside of time
so mathematics is true outside of time
if if uh if numbers were somehow or
other
which a small number of people believe a
kind of
part of the physical realm but a kind
but somehow attached to the physical
realm so if the physical realm didn't
exist
numbers wouldn't exist that would be a
simp eternal version
so in in casual talk we say yeah it's
eternal it's always the case
but this distinction like god standard
view of god
god is eternal outside of creation
right uh whereas whatever god created
is and if god created anything that
lasted forever
in creation that would be semp eternal i
see i see wittgenstein had a quote about
this
he said if eternal means infinite
temporal length
then that that would be right
if it didn't mean that but instead meant
outside of time then anyone who lives in
the present moment is living eternally
yeah well that's beautiful also a bit
mystical
a few weeks ago i emailed or maybe a
couple months ago i emailed you about
thought experiments
are i don't recall how the conversation
started but you sent me a book on
thought experiments you didn't know that
i was thinking of writing a book i
actually started but your book was
far more articulate than mine about
thought experiments just
i recommend people who watch facebook to
read it's like
it's like spit back second book on
manifolds it's a short read
and compendius
something i've been trying to develop is
is there a way
of formulating the laws of physics from
pure thought experiments
what drove me to think that was the
galileo experiment the thought
experiment with galileo
and you had already thought about this
as well and in fact you just started
writing a book about it's not like you
you solved the problem otherwise
we we'd invent plenty of new technology
but
you've made what i think is progress so
let's talk about that book
do you think that ultimately the laws of
physics can be generated from
armchair philosophy just sitting back
and thinking a thought experiment
uh certainly not all uh in fact not even
most
but just every now and then i think we
we can
learn something about the world in a
non-empirical way
and my favorite example
is galileo and falling objects
galileos galileo is a wonderful thought
experimenter
maybe the best ever uh he's absolutely
terrific uh einstein was a very good
thought experimenter too
um they're probably in the same league
but if anything i think galileo is
a notch above um
the my favorite thought experiment of
all time
and i remember hearing it when i was an
undergraduate and thought it was the
most dazzling thing i'd ever heard
and this is the uh argument for
all objects regardless of how heavy they
are fall
at the same rate so it's a thought
experiment
you imagine yourself going up on the
leaning tower of pisa if you like
and you're dropping a cannonball which
is quite heavy
and a musket ball which is relatively
quite a bit lighter
now the the common sense view and the
view
in uh in aristotle are the same it says
that heavy objects will just
fall faster than light objects and we've
got a lot of experience to that effect
you know
i mean if you do throw a cannonball and
a feather
you know you know that the cannonball is
going to hit the ground a lot sooner
um so galileo says all right
if uh heavy objects fall faster than
light objects
let's imagine a compound object
consisting of a cannonball
and a musket ball glued together okay
um and drop it now we've got three
things we've got a a cannonball
a musket ball and this composite objects
now on the principle the heavy objects
fall faster
this composite object is going to fall
fastest of all of the three
but unfortunately it's not it's going to
be slowed down by the fact that
the cannonball part of the composite
algae wants to fall
at its fast rate but it's going to be
held back by this little musket ball
attached to it
who's wanting to fall at a slower rate
so it's like jumping out of a window
with a little tiny parachute it's going
to slow you down
um and so that's absurd the composite
object will be both faster
and slower than the heavy canon ball by
itself
there it's and that was the end of
common sense
about falling objects and the end of
aristotle
on freefall and but the solution
how fast do things fall is obvious
when you've reached this point and
here's the here's where the
where a physical intuition actually
comes in and you don't need to perform
the experiment
you just think about it and you realize
oh they all have to fall
at the same rate and that'll
and that's how things fall right at the
same rate regardless of how heavy they
are
to me this is still one of the most
beautiful thought experiments as well
and it it's what led me on the journey
of thinking i wonder how much more of
physics can be gleaned
by just thinking about what's consistent
what contradicts
oh a ton of things um galileo's other
i think his other very very famous
thought experiment is the uh
inside the ship um where
he can't tell by hypothesis he can't
tell whether the ship
is stationary in the port or moving
across a very smooth ocean and he says
okay i'm inside
and birds are flying around inside
front to back and it's the same whether
i'm sailing or
at port i throw up a ball to my friend
back and forth same whether we're moving
or import fish are in a
in an aquarium tank inside the ship and
there
they swim back and forth in the tank and
it doesn't matter whether
we're stationary and moving everything
is the same on the inside
and that's his argument for um
what has become the principle of
relativity that
inertial frames the laws of nature are
exactly the same
in any inertial frame whether it's a
stationary one
at rest in port or moving smoothly over
the
over the sea um right what was the
impetus for him
thinking of this thought experiment was
it because he was suggesting the earth
is moving
and people were wondering well shouldn't
we be moving if the earth is moving or
was it something else
that's exactly right there was another
thought experiment prior
not galileo's but prior to galileo this
is a medieval thought experiment
sometimes called the tower
experiment and and that is if the earth
is moving either around the sun or
spinning on its own axis either way um
and you dropped an object from a from a
tower
then as the earth moved the object would
fall way behind the base of the tower
right never does that it always falls
right down at the base
right and you can use a similar ship
argument where if you're on a ship and
the ship is sailing and you drop a ball
it'll fall behind the ship or where the
tail end of the ship was that's right
the tower
that's what the the the equivalent tower
argument would use
but galileo says no no it's not going to
be like that at all if you're
uh if you're just inside the ship you
can't see out
you drop a ball it'll land at your feet
uh and if you're moving over the sea at
20 knots uh and you drop a ball it's
still going to land at your feet
either way right right and and
and that's that and then more general of
course you just make the claim
the laws of nature are going to be the
same in any inertial
frame of reference and that's the
principle of relativity that's galileo's
version
and it's the version it's the only
version we use
when einstein gave us a special
relativity
he hung on to the principle of
relativity because it was in danger
it was in danger from
maxwell's electrodynamics which seemed
to need a universal ether as if there
was a single frame
in which physics was correctly described
and um and and moving a moving anything
that was moving in the ether frame
you wouldn't get the right um
results that is that you'd have to take
that into account
the laws of nature now let's get to
with the absolute space and the bucket
so newton
had a thought experiment that
demonstrated absolute space
okay so this is a another extremely
famous thought experiment
and for this i can show a diagram
from the book or from any other place i
don't want to take from the copyright
holder
no no have you got it there no i mean
i'll show it when where when i'm editing
oh yeah yeah yeah you can show
it from my book don't worry sure yeah i
you i grant you permission
thank you i appreciate that
now um so newton gave two versions of
this
one was the bucket okay and and so
uh the way the way you should think of
it is you've got a bucket
um and you can you can twist the rope
okay and the and here's the bucket and
the water is very smooth on top
and you let the bucket go because it's
the only thing in the universe for this
for the well for the bucket there's all
there's there's newton and there's
everything
around okay never mind let me do the
bucket and then i'll switch to the other
one
which is the empty universe okay so um
at first the water is flat and the
bucket starts to rotate
and gradually so so and so initially
before anything happens the water and
the bucket are at rest with
respect to one another
then they start to rotate and they're
rotating together
both the bucket and the water and the
water starts climbing the walls
and then you stop the bucket and the
water's still climbing
and then it gradually subsides the flat
again
now the question is how do we how do we
explain the difference between
the water and bucket being at rest
initially and the water's flat
and later on the water and bucket are at
rest with respect to one another
but but the water is concave okay the
water is climbing up the walls
how do you explain the difference and
newton says okay um
you know what's going to happen here's
the explanation
in the first case the water bucket
system is not
rotating with respect to space
and later when the wall water's climbing
the walls
the whole system is rotating with
respect to space itself
and then conclusion therefore space
exists
it's not just you know something that uh
you know we're we use as a convenience
or something like that
actually let me go back and make sure
and and people can
figure out what their instinctive view
is
okay this will be the difference between
a newtonian on the one hand
and a leibnizian relationalist on the
other hand
okay question
if there was nothing in the whole
universe no
object existed anywhere in the universe
would space
still exist could space still exist
and i find that when i ask my students
that question
about half of them say yeah empty space
no problem this could be empty space and
the other half said
that's ridiculous there couldn't be such
a thing as empty space
if there's no objects there's just no
space period
this sounds like the tree falling in the
woods
the space-time version connection to
that you're right
and there's some there's a counterpart
to that for time
if i say to my class okay imagine
that nothing ever happened everything
was just frozen solid
could time still pass after class will
say no
no events no time the other half will
say
yeah time's still passing but nothing's
happening
very different instincts people have
about this and that one's also about 50
50.
yeah roughly 50 50. same people the same
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah they're highly
correlated okay
yeah so if you think empty space makes
sense
and you think time without events makes
sense you're a newtonian
you're with newton and if you think that
um
no objects no space or no events no time
you're an instinctive leibnizian a
relationalist
and what about you uh my instincts are
mostly with newton
it's also another thing that's
interesting about this is that
um my class will be typically half
physics staff philosophy students
it doesn't break along that line at all
oh interesting
half the physicists are newtonians in
instinct and half of them are live
nations
and the philosophy students exactly the
same half of them are newtonians half of
them are labnets again
have you done this with mathematicians
i'm curious
what they're have happened
mathematicians i do it with
mathematicians for other things
and often that are philosophically
interesting
and i am often surprised at
the split in the mathematical audience
exactly corresponds to the split in the
philosophy audience
that is you can't tell from someone's
answer whether they're a mathematician
or a philosopher
by the way do you consider are you a
professor of philosophy of math or
philosophy of physics or both
no just philosophy but my specialty
inside
is things like math and physics i see
some i mean some
philosophers are you know they
specialize in the history of philosophy
or in
ethics and so on uh math and physics are
my specialties inside as an aside
another aside why did you end up
choosing to go into the philosophy of
math instead of math is it just purely
based on what interested you
or was there something else
that's a really interesting question i
think
it was pretty much that right at the
beginning
like when you're beginning undergraduate
and you so then you have to pick majors
and stuff like that
i thought i can do
anything in the world as a philosopher
and no one will say yeah you're not
doing philosophy anymore
one of my first questions for this that
i wrote down it's has any philosophical
question ever been solved
and this relates to that because i'm
curious to know
it's something i've been thinking about
i didn't search this on google and it's
not clear the only one that i can think
of is maybe zeno's paradox with saying
well you're only accounting for finite
time
but have any major philosophical
problems ever been solved
um i'd be more confident in saying
a lot of views have been decisively
refuted
so there's a lot of people in philosophy
saying well
we don't know that we're we know we know
that we're making progress
in this limited sense that we now know
certain things are false that we didn't
know were false
you know 50 years ago or something like
that but i mean there are lots
i have lots of philosophical views uh
about which i'm fairly confident
and i think those might count people
would disagree with me of course
right but there'd be a there'd be a
some significant number of people who
say yeah
we think that's right in defensive
yeah i mean to take one of the one of
the most important
and oldest is plato's um
plato's refutation uh
for the need for god in order to have
objective ethics
it's in the dialogue called the
euthyphro
and it's a very simple little argument
and it doesn't it doesn't refute the
existence of god it just
says no no no objective ethics
objective right and wrong is completely
independent from god
god's got nothing to do with it it's a
wonderful little argument
and um if you are an atheist you're
happy with the conclusion
right we can have objective ethics we
don't need god
and if you do believe in god you could
say well i still believe in god and i
believe in objective ethics the intimate
connection that i thought was there
actually isn't there but
everything else is wonderful
or someone can reject the conclusion and
say yes god can advocate for
the murder of a child and that would
still be good because god advocated for
it
that's the essence of the euthyphro
argument because everyone will bark at
that
and they'll they think they they think
well something is moral because god says
so
and then you say oh yeah so if he told
you you had uh you had to rape every
woman you can see
then that would be a good thing to do is
that what you believe and no one will
believe that
and then they realize that this is
stupid i can't what i've been saying all
along is a really stupid view
the most we can get out of god is god is
a truthful reporter
of objective moral rules like we can
trust god to tell us
what the moral rules are but god isn't
making them they have to be independent
that's a really it's a it's a
wonderfully interesting problem
that's underappreciated i think
theologians
theologians don't don't want to touch it
and there's another one
that they even more don't want to touch
and that is um
how colorful god is
the one about ethics is a lot like what
leibniz thought about god's power
if you'd say liveness do you think god
is all-powerful you say you betcha
you can do anything
whiteness wouldn't say that though
because life is a qualification which
i'm going to give you in a second
okay okay you say descartes can god do
everything say you betcha he can do
anything
and then you say well can he make it
rain
it's a sunny day right here can you make
it rain sure you can make it rain
liveness could he make it rain you
better you can make a rain just like
that
um and then you say to descartes could
he make it rain
and not rain simultaneously
descartes would say yes he can even do
that i can't imagine what it would be
like
but he can do it and leibniz would say
no he can't do that
he can make it rain he can make it not
rain but he can't pull off a
contradiction
so god god can do anything that's
possible
that's god's power right and and that
and the light in its view about what god
can do in the physical realm
is very much like well liveness i think
with all the same view about ethics
you know god can advocate almost
anything but god actually couldn't make
murder okay god couldn't make torturing
kittens
morally okay he doesn't have that kind
of power
you know when we're talking about
whether or not philosophical problems
have been solved
something i found online which it's
funny it's a reason why
philosophical problems have not been
solved is that as soon as they have been
solved they get relegated to something
like physics or math
for example you know physics was called
natural philosophy before anyone would
know
that's a good that's actually a really
good point the hardest problems state in
philosophy the ones that are unsolvable
stay in philosophy as soon as they're
solved
they get outside the realm of philosophy
and that's why philosophical problems
seem to have never been solved
that's a really good point um uh
in fact that's how a lot of philosophers
think of their discipline
as giving birth to the sciences once
once we sort something out
um it takes off uh a life of its own
sometimes when i talk to hardcore
physicists they don't like to deal with
concepts that are
maybe you might call them thick although
i might be using your terminology
incorrectly
i might i'm gonna call them ambiguous
like for example
consciousness or free will or
yeah yeah those are those right and they
would just say i don't know what it
means to
i don't know what that means and so let
me just stay with my
rulers and protractors but the
philosophers are willing to deal with
what seems meaningless and try and find
meaning and then
and concretize what's ambiguous or
disambiguate what's ambiguous
and then it goes into another realm yeah
yeah
that's right and i don't particularly
like the the
this there's a dismissal that an
arrogance that comes from the purely
mathematical and purely physical
professors that i've spoken to where
they don't want to deal with
certain concepts that seem that are
ill-defined
they'll just say well i don't deal with
that and that's meaningless and so you
can pursue that but that's a religious
pursuit to even talk about consciousness
or
or what it means to die or what it what
does life mean
well uh yeah that seems rather
short-sighted because
uh so many i mean i i can understand
them
saying uh i i don't want to deal with
consciousness
as a physicist uh i'm very happy to talk
about it
um and think about it and reflect on it
it's probably
outside the realm of physics i'm also
very interested to talk about politics
and how we should organize society
but i wouldn't derive it from the
schrodinger equation exactly
right okay now the bucket
okay so anyway the the bucket um
the the uh newton's final conclusion
okay water still initially water concave
at the end what's the difference
explanation
the bucket is not rotating then the
bucket is rotating with respect to space
itself and therefore space exists it's
meant to be
an argument for the existence of space
as a thing in its own right
sp as well as all these material objects
all around us there is also
space it's an extra thing
like that said that's rubbish there's
nothing to space
except um the relations among physical
things
get rid of the physical things there's
nothing left over there's nothing so
likeness
didn't agree with the conclusion of the
thought experiment or he just didn't
get presented with this thought
experiment no that's that's really a
good point
um they had a wonderfully interesting
correspondence
back and forth it's called the leibniz
clark
correspondents because clark is very
close to newton
we don't really know whether
clark was simply taking dictation
from newton he might have been or he
might have just talked to newton about
how to formulate answers
but there's about six letters back and
forth between them
and they keep getting longer and longer
uh leibniz died
it never it never came to an end it just
leibniz just unfortunately died
um and leidness has wonderful answers to
a whole lot of stuff
that uh newton talks about
uh but why vanessa's a brilliant
brilliant person
when people are talking about the
luminaries they mention einstein and
newton
but leibniz is to me on the same
category of newton
oh he is he's unquestionably one of the
all-time
spectacular greats yeah yeah
universally right he's just brilliant in
everything
yeah okay okay okay so anyway but but
that's the bucket but you see newton uh
newton nsaid
gave a second version it's the same
argument but this is the really
interesting one
so uh he says uh you imagine two spheres
connected by uh a chord or a rod or
something
a chord negative chord or any lasting
and he says
um uh there there's a tension
in the elastic okay it's stretched um
the material
sorry sorry is this in your thought
experiment book as well that i can place
it
okay it'll be in the same place
okay i'm just trying to visualize it
right now it i'm visualizing something
like that it's like
it looks like a dumbbell okay so you got
the two spheres
and they could be made out of some
massive thing
you could be would if they don't attract
or retail but there's a tension
okay the chord is stretched okay okay
okay how could you explain this
there's nothing in the universe it's an
empty universe how do you explain it
newton says easy the whole thing is
rotating
and you see the the individual objects
try to move in straight lines they try
to move inertially
and hence they're it's stretching the uh
the cord between them
and that's how you account for it well
what's the cause
of this inertial motion space itself
space is the source of inertial motion
and inertial forces and stuff like that
this is the if now if you're if you're
um
if you're someone like leibniz you're
going to have real problems with this
because space see for newton space has
real properties
it can cause things it causes things to
move in straight lines
that's why if you throw an object no
force on it it'll move in a straight
line
it's space that sort of guides it as it
were that way
okay and if there were no space um it
there'd be no accounting for why it
moves in a straight line rather than
just
at random leidness leibniz
died before he could really tackle
that issue and he who knows he might
have even been won over by it
you wanted to know about how einstein
reacted to this
right einstein changed his mind but
early on
and this is at the in the very first
couple of pages in the
in the paper on general relativity for
the audience just to clarify
the newton bucket experiment
demonstrated at least for newton
the presence of absolute space
that's right space is a thing in its own
right
yeah um what what
what einstein does is he he
rejects the whole setup so he imagines
two spheres that are rotating with
respect to one another
and one is perfectly spherical and the
other one's a kind of um
um an ellipse of revolution
okay so it's elongated at its equator
okay just like our earth spinning on its
axis it's a little wider at the equator
so einstein imagines these two things uh
in an otherwise empty space and he says
how can you explain this
and then he says you can't you must
appeal
to distant matter in the presence of
this is
this is really mark's um answer to all
of this
you must appeal to distant matter that
you can
experience you can see it and uh
and one of the uh objects the the
ellipse of revolution
um that object not the spherical one but
that object is rotating with respect to
that distant mass
so it's not space itself
that causes the inertial motion it's the
presence of a
of billions of distribution okay
let me see if i have this correct
because i don't recall this so are you
is what you're saying something like we
don't know if we're rotating unless we
see
stars rotating above us
yeah or is this completely is it because
it's outside that's einstein
yeah okay what about the centripetal
force or centrifugal force
so what does he say about that we
wouldn't feel it
it's not caused by rotation with respect
to space
it's caused by rotation with respect to
distant matter
in fact this is mark
marx mark made an empirical claim about
this
and i don't think it's very practical so
no one can ever do it
but mark said imagine that you did
newton's bucket
in a bucket where the where the walls of
the bucket were several miles
thick okay okay
so imagine them 100 miles thick
incredible mass then you and you rotate
this thing
yeah okay so in newton's bucket when you
rotate it the wall the water starts to
climb the wall
yeah lock said if you've got enough mass
in the bucket
itself the water would stay level
uh-huh therefore it's not
rotation with respect to space it's
rotation with respect to
external masses this is the bucket it
depends on that
yeah but you need you need such a big
bucket
you know you couldn't you couldn't you
couldn't ask
the government to to pay for this
experiment
they would be they would be turfed out
of power in the next election when that
when the population got wind of it in
your thought experiment book
you fractionate into two there's
constructive destructive types of
thought experiments and then and then
constructive conjecture and so on
did you come up with that or was that
something you found
um there's a little bit in the uh um
well i should tell you when when i when
i first decided
what let me back up a little more when i
first heard about the galileo thought
experiment of the
falling bodies i thought that's the most
wonderful thing i'd ever heard
and then after i got tenure i thought
okay they can't fire me now return i'm
going to do
what i wanted to do for a long time and
i start thinking about
thought experiments and there's
virtually no literature on it
there's you know people make the odd
offhand remark and of course there are
lots of thought experiments floating
around
but nobody had ever written about it in
a collection what's their nature you
know how do they work and
stuff like that and i was shocked
that i could read uh almost everything
that had ever been written about thought
experiments in a long weekend
it was almost nothing a bit by mock and
a bit by
you know a few other people and that's
it
and um so the the few people who had
commented on it
usually divided things up into the
positive negative
kind of thought experiment thought
experiments which
you know get try to give you a new
theory versus thought experiments which
just
destroy an old theory
okay so schrodinger's cat is a negative
thought experiment in the sense that
it's just supposed to undermine
standard quantum mechanics um but other
other thought experiments like like
heisenberg's
mic gamma ray microscope which gives you
the uncertainty principle
that's more positive give you a new
positive result type thought experiments
so that there was a beginning of a
taxonomy
you know there then i then i just
fine-tuned it a little bit
okay you fine-tuned only the
constructive part well the destructive
part goes down to direct
so it's like i don't know what direction
and then one of the constructives goes
down to direct as well
yeah um i i think i can't remember now
whether i i mean there were some
distinctions i didn't bother making
but might have made in passing when i
was describing that taxonomy
um the negative thought experiments i
might have put them lumped them all
together is just
negative yeah um there's probably
uh an important difference between
uh negative thought experiments that
follow from the theory itself
which just shows that they're internally
incoherent
and negative thought experiments which
show a clash
between uh a theory and other
more or less established knowledge so i
would i could fine-tune there and you
could probably
make more distinctions and
anytime you're setting up a tech a
taxonomy there's a kind of balance
between
you know to what extent can this be
simplified and enlightening
and to what extent do you go into so
much detail it just becomes
you get lost and you get lost in the
detail
have you been keeping up with theories
of everything
there's been a couple of new ones this
year yeah a little bit
have you read up on wolframs or eric
weinstein's
no uh well from wilson's views
uh he just thinks that the world is an
automaton
and um uh he he sees digital computers
is answering all questions i
i'm i'm still sufficiently wedded to
continuity
in a lot of places that i don't i think
digitizing things is is only
a nifty approximation and uh good for
solving a lot of practical problems
but i don't think it's going to reveal
the deeper truth i may be wrong
i may be wrong um i have uh physics
friends
who do believe that space time is
discrete
yep and uh if they're right
then understanding the world in as a
gigantic digital computer um
that makes uh that becomes a little more
plausible
now you definitely should read that
paper that you sent me which i thought
that you knew nicholas jessen
and you were completely familiar with
his work but anyway just for the
audience remember i i did
i read it at the time i remember saying
i do remember sending it to you
but i just completely forgot it okay
is a physicist who was answering a
question that i was
curious about which is why i asked jim
here i said hey
is there any other
logical foundation of physics other than
classical logic
because i'm wondering i'm always i'm
curious like what's holding us back from
theories of everything and i'm trying to
tackle it from as many angles as i
as i can and so i thought maybe this is
one and you said well there is this
person named nicholas jessen who thinks
that intuitionist logic is a way to go
and i want to write that now i'm getting
i'm now it's coming back yes yes
okay and so what he was saying he has a
few different
reasons for believing that first of all
real numbers aren't real
and the reason for this is to say is
because there's only a finite amount of
information that can be in
any finite volume so let's say it's a
real number if it's an arbitrary real
number
then it's going to collapse into a black
hole if for whatever reason the particle
somehow carries that information with it
okay well you can leave and leave that
aside
he says that all of deterministic
physics like classical physics
actually is completely compatible with
an indeterministic view
forget about quantum mechanics and the
reason is that all we can do is test it
to a certain precision
let's say 30 decimal places that's
being a bit generous well let's say 30
decimal places for classical physics
then you can easily
construct indeterminate
um indeterminate functions so here's one
i can't say it because
i can't say it i would just have to
write the function out but let's say you
have the real line so zero to one
and then you you somehow stretch the
real line and then you cut the real line
in half
i'll have to tell you what the function
is but either way
that real line you can describe any
number as zero point
b one b two be like the digits of okay
great what that function effectively
does
is remove the first digit so instead of
it being zero point b one b two b
three it's zero point b2 b3 b4
okay now given that
given that let's say finite
let's say non-real numbers are
completely compatible with classical
physics because
we don't know where the end
of the error bar effectively gives
a a real number or if it's just
cut off you understand you understand
what i'm saying sorry if i'm
if i'm not explaining correctly okay
given that
then we can have these simple systems
that actually are not just
chaotic because we don't have sufficient
information but because
within it it genuinely is indeterminate
for example that function like if you
just choose an arbitrary okay so you get
the idea
okay so then he was saying that
indeterminacy is not incompatible with
classical physics even though
we like to think of classical physics as
being a determinant theory
you can't it's so then he goes on to say
calling physics deterministic or
indeterministic is not a scientific
question because both models predict the
exact same reality that we see
classically forget about quantum
mechanics
and then he goes on to make a connection
between that and free will
he's a proponent of free will much like
yourself and he says it can be saved
the clas the libertarian version of free
will not the compatibilist that is that
i choose from the possible world
well anyway that's extremely intriguing
to me like one
so i thank you so much for that and i'm
going to talk to nicholas about that
good oh that that's i'm i'm i'm glad you
got so much out of it
my instincts are to uh disagree uh
quite strongly um to start with i'm
a a realist and a platonist about math
not a constructivist not an intuitionist
so i think all those decimal expansion
to infinity
it exists um but it exists in plato's
heaven
so i don't know how he's i don't know
where black holes would come in unless
he's trying to physicalize the numbers
and then the decimal representation
would require an infinite amount of ink
in a very small space and collapse into
a black hole
some now i'm i'm i'm sort of joking and
saying yeah i understand
but the thing is um i think uh
you need real numbers
irrational real numbers in uh
in physics um think of try try to
imagine doing physics without pie
which is uh an irrational number
okay it's got an infinite decimal
expansion try to try to imagine doing
physics
without um the square root of two
square root of two comes up all over the
place in just in quantum mechanics
you've got a
two-state system you know it can it
could be
an upper or down and you describe the
state as one over root two
up plus one over root two down
and then to get the probability you
square that so
square one over root two squared is one
becomes one half and that of course you
can measure accurately but you're gonna
always represent it as one over root two
you
you're gonna have to appeal to these now
he may say
ah but i'm only appealing to an
approximation of one over root two
like i only need five if i went five
decimal places
and so i'm really it's really a rational
number that's all i need for
complete empirical adequacy it would be
hard to argue with him over that
i think my my best argument against him
would be the utter simplicity of the
real numbers
as opposed to truncating them and
turning them into
uh rational numbers to do physics
but but from an empirical point of view
i may have to concede
that there's not going to be any
empirical distinction
right between the two right okay i'm
gonna read from your
book oh before i get to that you did
mention that there are some examples of
non-platonic forms of mathematical
realism
i i can't conceive of that so do you
mind expounding you said
you said that mill or kitcher kitcher
yes that's right or
oh yes yes yes yes sure okay uh he um um
mill is easy he's the classic example
so he's he'd be you'd call him a
mathematical realist
almost everybody who which mill is this
uh john stuart mill
okay okay almost everybody who's a
mathematical realist uses
realism platonism roughly
interchangeably
i mean they might they might want to
make some fine distinctions
uh and that's because almost everybody
who is a realist
is happy to be called a platoonist but
there is
mill is a mathematical realist who is
absolutely not a platonist
so for nil numbers are really just um
a kind of abstraction from the physical
realm
they're part of the physical realm a bit
like colors so when i say
2 plus two equals four i'm actually
talking about
physical stuff so two apples
it's just a short form for a more
general
as a generalization of two apples plus
two apples equals four apples
two liters of water plus two liters of
water is four liters of water
etc etc etc i just i just simplify it to
two plus two equals four
but it is learned empirically and it's
about the physical empirical world
that's mill okay
um fraga made a lot of fun of him
nobody believes bill they think it's
preposterous view
uh but you see how it's realist in the
sense that
it's about reality and it's meant to be
literally true
yeah i just don't see how it's not
platonistic so can you help me out
because if it's saying that the
generalities are true what does he mean
by true where do they exist
so if you're saying that if i said if i
said these apples are red
yeah okay that's a straightforward
empirical realm
uh the the the fact that they're really
lengthy
right here this this is it and if i said
these two apples and these two apples
make four apples
it's all about what's right here okay
there's nothing about plato's heaven in
that it's all right here
it's just that when i say two plus two
equals four without reference to apples
or liters of water or
or or chocolate biscuit or anything like
that
um it's it's a it's kind of abstracted
from but it's really about
the physical realm uh uh okay so let me
see if i get the difference
okay okay the platonist would say
you're reflecting some other truer world
and mill would say you're
predicated on this world it's true but
it's dependent on this world not some
other world
is that what you mean yeah but mill
would say and there's no other world
it's just this one
um uh the closest i can think of
for an analogy would be talking about
colors
so i mean i can say this apple is red
that banana is yellow
but i can say at a slightly more
abstract level but i'm still here in the
world
red plus yellow make orange
see i'm i'm still here in the imperial
world
yeah i see even though i'm not talking
about a particular apple or a particular
banana but
red plus yellow make orange so why is
that ridiculous
why is mills what you said that mill is
laughed at by fraga and many other
mathematicians
if the universe if the universe is
finite if if we thought it was finite if
we
just standard big bang the universe is
finite
there's only finitely many elementary
particles in it there's only finitely
many things in it
that means there's the biggest number
and i say oh let's call it
n biggest number that's it i say well
what about n plus one do you think n
plus one is bigger than
n and of course you'd say of course it
is
and mill doesn't know how what's mill
going to say there's no such numbers
in plus one you're just making it up i
see
and so it just seems preposterous we
believe there are infinitely many prime
numbers
infinitely many numbers mill doesn't
know actually what to do with this
if the universe is finite
if the world if the universe is infinite
he got lucky and maybe he can get around
that problem
but he's going to have a lot of problems
why does the universe being finite mean
that there has to be a finite
conceptual number because even with the
if you think of numbers
if you think of numbers as as
uh as ref with reference to the physical
world
okay if you think of them as
independently existing in plato's heaven
no problem the world could be the world
could just cease to exist and still
all all those all those things in plato
seven would be just fine
could you still not save it by saying
for example right now on my desktop i
have a few items
and then there's a there's n factorial
way of
well not your n but a little little case
n way factorial way of
of arranging them and then you just keep
adding so no matter what even when you
okay yeah yeah you can keep doing the
combinatorics
um ad nauseam but you're still never
going to break out of the finite realm
because let's say we okay i'm just
trying to grapple with this so let's say
we come up with large n so that's your n
then i say
well let's still permute that a bit more
and then we get n
factorial the big n factorial and then
we say well that's a maximum then we
just factorial again and we still get
infinity so we still get any possible
number can be reached with this number
they have to be tied somehow to the
empirical world remember he's a staunch
imperial
empiricist and he doesn't like platonism
he doesn't like
abstract entities so um if i had
um if i have two apples
if i have two apples i can say okay one
two and then i can bunch them together
and say i can say now that's a third
object
okay okay so he would have a he would
have a problem with possibilities
the reason why yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's right because
they have to be concrete i have to be
measuring four apples i could say that
possibly
you can arrange them in eight but that's
because there exists something else
that's
i can concretize is eight sure okay okay
okay that's right
okay i get it i get it now i'm going to
read the last part of of your book which
i found
wonderful you say this my suggestion is
very
simple distant correlations are caused
by the laws of nature
i realize this almost sounds silly one
wants to say the correlations are the
laws of nature
but this if you recall in the preceding
chapters is not true
a law of nature is an independently
existing abstract entity a thing
in its own right which is responsible
for physical regularities
okay now this was in regards to
something called
the entanglement of bells inequality but
we can forget about that what you're
suggesting is that the physical laws
themselves are akin to entities
and i haven't heard that expressed
before and i think that's going to take
me maybe
maybe weeks or months to to fully
apprehend
and and perhaps even contribute some of
my own ideas to
it's a it's a brazen statement and i'm
i'm a fan of audacity so
can you expound on this yeah um
i'm not sure i i wrote that quite a
while ago and my views on quantum
mechanics are constantly in flux
so i'm not sure i would uh agree with
that
in particular however with the general
idea i certainly still
i still think that is true so let me
explain um
what i'm trying to get at for most
philosophers
they really really like david hume
david hume has a view about the nature
of causation
and the nature of laws of nature which
is very empiricist
and what it really amounts to is that a
law of nature is nothing but
a an empirical regularity so if i say
um um all ravens are black
or it's a law of nature that ravens are
black
what it just means is that um uh
every time i see a raven it's black
that's it that's all there is to it um
it's just away with causation yeah
causation is like that too
um fire is fire feels hot every time i
stick my hand in a fire it feels hot
the heat doesn't cause the pain it's
just correlated with the pain
okay every time i stick my hand in the
fire i feel pain
um it's just it's just this regularity
there's nothing more to causation than
the regularity
there's nothing more to a law of nature
than irregularity
so if i said explain why this raven is
black
hume would have to say um all ravens are
black
this is a raven therefore this is black
that's the only explanation he can give
his laws of nature are really just
summaries of
what we experience they can't really
explain anything they don't have any
explanations
they're like data points and then
generalizations
and then and then the law is nothing but
uh a summary of the data points okay
yeah there's no there's no explanatory
power there
okay now uh if you're a staunch
empiricist you're happy with that
you say science is in the business of of
organizing experience and predicting
experience but we're not in the business
of
actually explaining things okay
get explanation that's not our business
okay um i hate that view i think we're
in the business of explaining and
understanding
and stuff like that so a lot of
hard-nosed empiricists would call me
oh it's just mushy sentimental nonsense
but i'm sticking to my sentimentality
and i want understanding and i want
explanations and so on
so here's an alternative view of laws of
nature
laws of nature are not just regularities
they're actually connections between
properties
so i'll stick to the raven example even
though
it's it's probably a poor example but
it's very easy to understand
and illustrate so when i say uh
so there's properties raven there's the
property of ravenhood
okay that is the property of being a
raven being a member of a
set of ravens is ravenhood sure okay
okay and there's the property of
being black okay okay so the law of
nature is not the regularity
that all ravens are black the law of
nature is
that the property of being a raven
is connected to the property of being
black
and that then that that's the law of
nature
and that law of nature forces the
regularity
that all ravens are black it's the law
that explains why the raven is black why
is why is this raven black
it's a raven it has the property of
ravenhood and that necessitates
the property of blackness okay okay
that's
that's that's it i mean it sounds it
sounds like
hokey nonsense but the thing is you're
actually
um introducing something new in the
world
um over and above the mirror regularity
and that has explanatory power
okay so the way that i'm thinking about
this is that there's a set of all black
objects and then ravens are a subset of
that
but i don't see what what's different
than what
a human is saying there'll be a property
a property of ravenhood
and a property of blackness and it's not
just
a coincidence but but there's a kind of
what's sometimes called a gnomic
connection
uh this is like a physical necessity
uh between the property of ravenhood and
the property
of uh blackness there's a
necessity between the property of
electron hood
and negative charge okay
okay it's not just it's not just a an
accidental correlation
there's something deep yeah
i guess where i'm having trouble is i'm
for an electron it's like we define it
as that which has
this if we found an electron with a with
negative two instead of negative one
we wouldn't call it an electron we call
it something else
probably that's true um but that but
that's
uh um that's a that's
that's an evidential thing uh uh of
course all of this is fallible
when i say all ravens are black it's a
law of nature that rage
could be mistaken we could we could find
in madagascar
you know ravens that are uh green or
something like that
but you're saying okay hypothetically so
i'm trying to i'm trying to understand
this so hypothetically you're saying
there that a property of ravenhood is
that it's black
okay okay so what does this have to do
with
sorry what does this have to do with
causality
uh okay so um
let me let me back up and make and make
this view of laws of nature a bit more
plausible
the hume view so you see hume view it's
just a regularity that all ravens are
black
now let us suppose you're you're doing
this video from your
house right or your apartment
let's suppose that every human being
who's ever been in that apartment
has worn socks okay
yeah so is it a law of nature
that everyone who enters kurt's
apartment
wears socks of nature
in this house it is it doesn't sound
like hello nature but it's a regularity
and that apartment might be blown up
tomorrow so that in its entire history
it was always true every time someone
entered that apartment they wore socks
see oh that's not a law of nature that's
just one of those
accidents how can i distinguish a
genuine law of nature
which is irregularity for hume from
these accidental
things hume has no answer
there's no way you can separate the two
but if you believe that laws of nature
are
properties then i would say it's it's
the law of nature uh about ravens being
black
the property of ravenhood necessitates
the property of blackness
okay however the property of entering
kurt's apartment does not necessitate
the property
where saw that was just contingent that
was just that's right
and so now you know still uh empirical
science has to discover
what are the accidental regularities
versus one or the laws
that can be really hard but the thing is
there is a metaphysical difference
between the two
and hume hasn't got a metaphysical
difference between the two
it's just wow it's just a big
coincidence
okay so now what does that have to do
with
with causation is just the flip coin of
laws of nature
so it is the law of nature that a's our
b's
is the same as a's cause b's
yes yeah what i'm curious about what i
found most fascinating was that it was
as if you're saying
e equals m c squared is it's like an
object itself that comes in and
influences
the world yeah yeah um it's hard to
figure out what
what the law of nature would be i mean i
can say it's a law of nature
e equals mc square um
it may be hard to figure out uh
putting it in these metaphysical terms
the property of energy and how it's
related to the property of mass and the
property of
speed of light and stuff like that but
they'll
on this view there would be such a
relation
a relation of necessitation between
energy as a property and mass as a
property
have you heard of lee smullen's
principle of precedence
i know him well and i have heard of it
and i have forgotten what it is
okay it's it's something like that
one of the reasons the electron
collapses in the way that it does
or that sorry this explains decoherence
i believe
that the reason why a large object
collapses
is because by chance somewhere else in
the universe a large
object has collapsed in a similar manner
and it's
felt at some other part of the universe
the patterns are felt and so they
collapse similarly
and that explains some of the
regularities to use that word
okay that's the principle um i i don't
know what to say about that
um i should i i just gonna i'm just
gonna have to go and and
right right right right well what i was
wondering is i'm curious if that merges
both platonists
and non-platonist because it's as if
it's formulating something that's true
and putting it into this
world that we now look to to represent
reality
but it was it was being invented at some
point yeah invention and discovery
that's
that's that's interesting the way you
put it i'm
inclined to think it's not because as i
said i know him quite well
and we argue over the issue of platonism
all the time
he's very antiplatenous yeah
um many are physicists generally
antiplateauous and mathematicians are
pro
no no they're a mixed bag on it
they're all over the place most most
working physicists i would say don't
have strong views
about the nature of mathematics that for
them it's a tool
they use it they just sort of grab it
out of the tool bag use what they want
and don't have philosophical views about
it they if you if they work in
fundamental physics
as lee smalling does he has very strong
philosophical views about the nature of
physics
you know is he a realist is he you know
what
and so on he's unquestionably a
scientific realist when it comes to
physics
but he's an anti-realist when it comes
to mathematics interesting
same with uh carlo rodelli
who uh uh smolin and rovelli uh
often work together uh ravelli's
i've gotten to know rovelli quite well
because he now lives in london here
he's my name cool um
and he's uh he's unquestionably a
scientific realist
when it comes to physics um
but hostile to platonism
but this is true for both ravelli and
smolin
they can't quite put their finger on
what it is they dislike about platonism
so much
so they're not winning the argument yet
so it's just an
a feeling that they have but they
dislike it because it has a mystical
quality to it
not sure okay
jim thank you again so much i appreciate
it a great pleasure
do you think we can derive an is from an
odds or an odd from an is
that's a really hard question uh
the simple answer is no
um because one is an imperative sentence
and the other's a declarative sentence
i mean just logically grammatically
they're they're going to be
different kinds of things we can come
close
um how can we come close well we can
come close in the sense that
let me let me actually back up and talk
about it in a very indirect way
okay um there's a traditional view
that there's a distinction between facts
and values it's the same thing
there's just a cleavage between the two
and science is totally concerned
with the facts and morality and
maybe religion and and other things
could be concerned with values
the trouble with that view is that um
too many things in science it's messy
um there are all kinds of values even in
just doing science itself
so for instance i can tell you about how
to find out an infinitude of facts
and maybe one of them you might be
interested in
so what is the distance between the tip
of my nose
and the center of mass of the sun now
i'm going to move
no i can ask you about the center of
mass of your nose and the center of mass
of that guy
on the street from his nose to the
center of mass of the moon
you could measure all of those things
and they would all be
factually correct if you measured
correctly
but after one or two of these you
that's enough and you're going to make a
value choice
that pursuing more of these is not
worthwhile
and that there are other things that are
more valuable so all facts aren't on a
par
some are clearly better than others
and and you as a scientist are going to
make these kinds of value judgments all
the time
and you're going to make methodological
value judgments which are even more
important
like you're going to say okay i've got
two theories here which one
should i believe oh this one's simpler
well that's actually a value judgment
that simplicity is to be preferred to
complexity
when you're talking about scientific
theories so right away
so all right so we've got these two
theories i choose this one on the basis
of simplicity
and now now i say oh well the facts
according to this theory
are different than the facts according
to that theory what are the facts
well i've just decided on this theory so
now i found out what the facts are
but it is it is value-laden in the sense
that i've
chosen this theory on the basis of its
simplicity
so you see how the values begin to
to to infect the um the facts
themselves and once you get into fairly
sophisticated science
and met and you're making methodological
choices about how to pursue
this you'll find that there's all kinds
of values that are getting
tied up in there and it's very very hard
to disentangle them
so in essence no it's not possible to
derive an art from an is
that's right you can't on the other hand
the more important question is can you
disentangle
your oughts from your is-is and the
answer to that question is i think
no and so now making a big fuss about
the distinction between israel
is probably a bad idea so when you're
looking at another scientist
don't ask just give me the facts
because a good scientist wouldn't be
able to
who had a sophisticated view of this
issue would not be able to tell
you what are the clear facts and how
much
the facts as presented in fact depended
upon
value decisions made along the history
the whole history of science
up to that point now that doesn't mean
you can
just say well i'm a racist
i'm proud of my values and i'm gonna and
i'm gonna let that guide my research you
know from here on in
you can't get away with that stuff
though lots of people try
but i do mean that there's going to be a
lot of values that you're not even aware
of
and they have um they have been
sprinkled through the entire history of
science
up until the present day and it'll
continue to be like that
what's your problem with sam harris you
said that you have he's a militant
atheist
as a mother a militant atheist uh so i
have no trouble with sam harris on that
front
the only thing i dislike about sam
harris and oh by the way he was the
voice of reason
uh in his uh discussion with jordan
peterson
so you agreed with them there oh
completely yeah yeah
much more than i was expecting because
i've seen sam harris before and
he sort of irritates me you don't like
his views on something
well you see there's a lot of militant
atheists
and often they're condemned as a group
hitchins
dawkins you know and harris dennett
and uh and sam harris um but
harris harris worries me unlike the
others um
and the thing that worries me is that he
has a special
hatred for muslims i don't i think
muslims have
ridiculous religious views just like
christians have ridiculous
religious views as do hindus and
buddhists and so on
they're all just ridiculous but
but i think in especially in this age
in the current conditions to to for
anyone to pick on
muslims uh especially in the united
states
it's um it's bordering on you know a
kind of
um a real bigotry that uh is
is worse than unhealthy what if you're
just criticizing islam and not the
muslim people themselves
uh this is tricky um you can criticize
islam
except that there are islam is actually
the belief held by people so
you can't criticize islam without
criticizing
um people who are or muslim maybe that's
one of the problems is that
intellectuals like yourself like i we
like to debate
ideas and it's difficult to detach our
eagles from the ideas
but we know that okay when a better idea
comes along we adopt that and we
take a little hit to the ego but we're
different than our ideas
so there is a separation between the
people and then the
uh sure sure uh and i have no no trouble
with that the trouble is
when you're talking to an in a mass
media and talking to a mass audience
and you start railing against islam it
just spills over
to a dislike of that guy who's sitting
next to you who happens
to be a muslim yeah so i don't trust him
um i so i just want to make sure i
understand it so something like when you
criticize islam
it's easily construed as criticizing
muslim people and then the effects of
you criticizing islam is
that other people are going to look at
muslim people with a negative light
that's right
yeah i mean i don't like islam any more
than i like christianity
but if i had a company and i'm going to
hire people i'm not going to
discriminate against muslims
i wouldn't hire a christian over a
muslim right that seems to me to be just
grotesque bigotry i would hire an
atheist over anybody
but when it comes to religions i i think
if you're going to criticize them
you criticize them all religions are
equal in that they're all equally
equally
uh groundless and yeah i think they've
done
i think religion is one of the worst
things that's ever happened to us
humanity yeah done a great deal of harm
let's get to platonism
let's get to platonism because this is
your domain this is what you are
so let's explain what platonism is and
then let's give people a test so that
they can find out if they're platonist
or not
all right well when i uh when i teach
topics related to this i usually ask my
my students on the very f at the very
beginning
whether they think mathematics is
discovered
or invented is it discovered like
physics
or is it invented like the game of chess
and i'll get very mixed reactions what
is it 50 50
no i'd say more on the discovery side
but a very sizable number on the
invention side let's say two-thirds
one-third
something like that and
and then i tell them things that often
surprise them
and that is that working mathematicians
are overwhelmingly
platonous that is a platonist is
very briefly believes that mathematics
is there waiting to be discovered
it's independent from us mathematical
facts
would be true even if no one ever
discovered them even if there were no
intelligent creatures
in the entire history of the universe pi
would still be an irrational number
um on the other hand chess would not
exist if there were no intelligent
beings
okay most working mathematicians now you
you were a math student so you may have
picked this up from your teachers
most working mathematicians are in fact
platonous they believe that
when they do mathematical research
they're investigating something that's
there
waiting to be discovered and if they get
it right
they have discovered something new
okay so that's that's a that's platonism
in a nutshell
and you're a platonist i am a plague so
what does it mean to exist
what does that mean because i actually
consider myself to be a plaintiff i
would actually think that the game of
chess
does exist in some form in the fact in
in the sense that there are these rules
and game theoretically you can construct
a model of chess and so that
you can if you can form a mathematical
model of it then it exists
you're right you're right uh so my
example
you can fuss with my example and but
it's just meant to be a crude example
for
for forgetting can we not then
extrapolate it and say that everything
that
possibly is logical exists
well there is a view um about possible
worlds
okay so um whenever we speak
in a certain mode like i say
there are no elephants in this room but
it is possible that there is an elephant
in this room it's not actual
but it is possible what does that mean
right now
what does that even mean well one view
says
you have to understand reality as made
up of possible worlds
the actual world is one world and
another world
there's another world that's almost
exactly like this one
there's a counterpart i'm in it
multiverse theory of quantum mechanics
yeah completely different yeah yeah this
is a this is a logical thing not a
physics thing
um so there's another possible world
that's exactly like this one
except there's an elephant over there in
the corner okay
otherwise they're exactly the same that
is a possible world
and when i and for me to say
it is possible that there is an elephant
in this room
that is a true sentence because there
exists a possible world
with an elephant in it yeah okay can we
not extrapolate that to god
that it's true that god exists that's
really an interesting question and it's
actually debated
because it sounds like well maybe
atheism is true in this world
but maybe there's another world and
which there is a god
that's going to be problematic uh but
it's
but it's actually up in the air it's
logically terrible
at least there's it's not clear it's not
clear that it's logically tenable and
that's why it's controversial
because intuitively it seems like it
ought to be yeah if an elephant can be
here
then why can't we make an abstract
notion of something yeah there could
have been a god there just isn't
okay that sounds sensible but if there
could have been a god
then there will be a god in a possible
world
the trouble with that is the way we
conceptualize god
is god is a necessary being and that
means if god
exists at all god must exist in every
possible world
it's a kind of all or nothing entity
because of the way
because omnipresence the presence of god
not just omnipresent but i mean in every
world
whether there is a god or not it's not
an option
it's either in no world or in every
world mathematics is like this
see if pi is an irrational number then
pi
is an irrational number in every
possible world there's no world in which
it's equal to three and a quarter or
something like that
okay it's always irrational and it's the
same with god
uh either god just can't exist it's
impossible it's like a contradiction
wait
how's that how's that commensurate with
the elephant though because to me if you
can
construct an elephant in another world
how do you know that that elephant
being true now we have to get to some
physics but how do you know
that that elephant can logically exist
just like logically pi is irrational
okay what we can prove that pi is
irrational now we're saying there's an
elephant in this room
and we're saying that that's possible
how do we know that's possible how do we
know that's a possibility just like
we know for sure pi is irrational um
okay uh
fair enough prima facie it's possible
like you can't think of any principled
objection to there being an elephant in
this room
you say well how did it get here you
know uh
answer they it's a small elephant they
brought it up in the elevator
walked it over here and it's been
sitting here since we started talking
you can easily imagine a scenario in
which you know something like that
is is the case so
the possibility of an elephant in this
room
is is a pretty clear case of of a
possibility
um but the god the the god one that's
our
that's a really hard not to crack
because it seems like god
because remember god is defined in a
certain way
in fact some people even define god as
the necessary being
and then anything that's necessary must
be true in every possible world this is
standard logic talk about possibility
um and god would have the same status as
2 plus 2 equals 4. if it's true anywhere
it's true everywhere
2 plus 2 equals 5. if it's false
anywhere it's false
everywhere okay and uh so god is either
like
one or the other i'm come down on the
side that god's like
a contradiction and absurdity well that
only disproves the
christian notion of god so what about
these hindu notions of god or others oh
yeah that's fine yeah so then they could
exist they could exist
yeah you're against an omnipresent
necessary
don't say omnipresent say uh um
omnipresent just means god is everywhere
in space
that's that's unchristian and unmuslim
um
the standard view is god is external
outside of space and time
and and can observe us cognizes us
but isn't in here participating okay
might intervene for a miracle here and
there
but the idea that god is one of us like
that song god is one of us just a
stranger on the bus and so on
that's that's heresy for christians
wouldn't christians say that you're made
in the image of god there's a little bit
of god in you and every time you act
god is almost acting through you when
you make a decision it's like you're
a consciousness that's gonna they're
they're gonna take that as a metaphor
i'm just debating what if it's not what
if that is the christian notion of god
that actually there's a little spark
there is an external god but also he's
in you as well
okay could that exist in these possible
worlds is that commensurate with the
idea of
not not if it's not if it's part and
parcel of a certain kind of god who
can't exist in principle but a lesser
god
uh i mean look you know the difference
between deism and theism
uh theism is like standard religion
organized religion
uh god is uh god cares about you
okay god is a person and it's a personal
god
uh you can talk to god might he might
answer your prayers you know all that
sort of stuff
that's that's a theistic view a deistic
view of god just says
there is a kind of supernatural creator
of all of this
but he doesn't give a damn about us
maybe he died after he created it
maybe even he's a committee you know
maybe there's 27 of them
and they fought over the details and
that's why a lot goes wrong
and it doesn't intervene set things up
to just run like a
a magnificent clock that's that's a
deism yeah okay so 18th century
uh would-be atheists were often dias
and that's because darwin hadn't come
along yet and they they couldn't make
sense of
design in nature and they thought you
have to have an intelligent
designer for this they couldn't escape
that they certainly didn't believe a
word of christianity
but they did believe in some kind of
intelligent creator of all of this
and that's a very common view in the
enlightenment the american
founding fathers you know like jefferson
[Music]
franklin washington they were deists
they weren't christians
americans don't even know their own
history they make a big deal of being a
christian nation actually they started
out as a
as an anti-christian nation
so you must love america
not with trump
[Laughter]
i should explain sokol's motivation okay
so sokol is very left-wing very
concerned with social issues
and um he was worried that um
well like me he is also i'm also
quite concerned with a whole lot of
social issues and i worry about students
who who would become
you know um socially active in in a
efficient and productive way because
they're pro
science they're willing to you know get
the facts right
and do serious investigations into
the social situation and so on the
trouble with postmodernism it becomes
a bit lazy uh it's given to
sloganeering it's given to
analyses that um that
well i don't know they they see certain
things as as political that aren't
political
and and and often just pick up the wrong
end of the stick anyway sokol as you
already indicated
submitted this ridiculous paper and said
i'd like to publish this and it made
all kinds of claims um using
quasi technical jargon
and some of the things you would know so
he said mathematics supports a woman's
right to an abortion
it's in the form of the axiom of choice
do you know this
okay now you having a math background
you understand that the axiom of choice
has got nothing to do with
free will choice and whether you have an
abortion
um so it was full of jargon
just ridiculous jargon like this and the
and the editors published it
i've always had a bit of a guilty
conscience about it even though i
completely support sokol
and his motivation i was editing a
journal at the time
and when i saw the headline in the new
york times
it was on the front page and all i could
i
choked oh oh god this could happen to me
i wonder if anybody's hoaxing me and
the thing is in the popular press
there's all this talk about
peer review and and they don't really
understand
the peer review process and why you
would ignore the
the process in certain cases and do
something else
and it's not intellectual corruption is
just something else that's going on
so if you've got a journal a physics
journal
it's a very well established discipline
with methodological guidelines that have
been
laid down they're reliable and if
somebody follows them they can be okay
if they violate them badly
you think look this is a piece of
garbage we're not going to take it
seriously but if you're starting a new
field like postmodern accounts
of post-modern accounts of science or
something like that you don't have a
long tradition that you can
point to and say this is this sort of
thing works that sort of thing does
you're you're you're you know you're in
virgin territory
and people who are doing that actually
need to be
you know encouraged and given courage to
explore
yeah and given a lot of free reign don't
come down on them too hard
for for you know um publishing
stuff that turns out to be crap now what
about the grievance study
affair well i'm i'm in favor of um
giving them a lot of free reign
by by grievance studies you mean things
like women's studies
black studies aboriginal studies and so
on no i think what's the reason folks
that came out yeah yeah i don't know i
don't know it well i read a very short
article on it
but i don't like the spirit behind
attacking them
i think they do need to be attacked
every now and then and
they certainly can't shouldn't just
think that they can
do any old crap at all but often they're
trying
to do stuff and they don't have set
guidelines to know
when when something is going to work
well and when something isn't going to
work well
they want to encourage a very generous
and broad
conversation about issues and i think
that's fair
and it's intellectually healthy and in
line with
academic freedom and in and and and it's
part and parcel with academic freedom
the only thing i have against
postmodernism
not not these other not these
disciplines like women's studies or
anything like that
i think it's terrific i think we should
have women's studies and so on
um but i am on the pro-science side of
the left
and that's because i think once you if
you're if you're a serious
post-modern who says oh truth truth
smooth
you know uh facts smacks you know
whatever
um you end up shooting yourself in the
foot
it's really really important to get
things like
global warming right in order to you
know to understand what's going on
and to and to tackle it um politically
to solve these problems i don't i don't
see that postmoderns have ever done
anything useful in combating
climate change the facts about racism
the facts about the climate the facts
about
the pharmaceutical industry those things
are really important
that we get those things out
there might be some truth to this so i
usually back off
and say well you know some approximation
to
an egalitarian socialist world um
and maybe some people are five times as
well off as other people
but that would be such an incredible
improvement over the current situation
that i'd be i'd go happily to my grave
you know if the difference between the
poorest and the richest we're only
five-fold in wealth as you know it's
much much much much greater than that
now um i also think
uh what i care about most of all
um uh you see a lot of people care about
rights and they care about freedom and
freedom of speech and
and so on and i think those things are
important
but i think human well-being trumps
everything
if all humans are reasonably well-off
and they're happy
and content then that's the kind of
world i want
if they if we have to sacrifice some
rights
say you even limit freedom of speech to
some extent for that
i'd be willing to do that i think going
to the wall
for complete freedom of speech for
instance is a complete mistake
i like canada's laws uh we have a great
a great deal of freedom of speech here
but not complete so for instance
that we have hate laws i'm i'm in favor
of hate laws
now i have lots of philosophical
colleagues and american friends and so
on
who think the us is much better in this
regard there's just no
constraints on your speech i mean you
can't you can't libel someone
you can't incite violence yeah you can't
incite violence but but you can
you can deny the holocaust in the united
states
you could declare that muslims are a
treacherous group of people and they
ought to be
uh oppressed and so on uh you can't say
that in canada you could be
you know prosecuted under the law for
that i favor
those constraints on freedom of speech
and i would favor probably other
constraints too
on other kinds of things that we
consider free
for in exchange for an enormous
increase in human well-being that we're
happier healthier we have richer lives
people can intellectually develop and
physically develop
you know to the best of their abilities
that's the kind of world i want
that's a very much a left-wing view of
things
um i think that ought to be
you know as far as you go but it's going
a hell of a long way
um usually when the left is is uh
attacked for
going too far it's either they want they
want to use a great deal of force to
bring about egalitarianism that's one
way and the other way
is the political correctness they're
accused of excessive
political correctness i think that's
just
almost always that's a false charge
that's just a bogus charge
that's like donald trump you know
complaining that
millions of people uh are streaming
across the mexican border
murdering and raping it's just a lie
right it's just a grotesque lie
okay um there is something
we never actually talked about this but
i'm going to interject this
because this is an illusion back to what
we were talking about earlier
political correctness is not a threat to
the university
we're incredibly free to do whatever the
hell we want
nobody is being uh suppressed inside a
university
it's a remarkable universities are
remarkable institutions i think they're
wonderful institutions but what about
what happened with jordan peterson where
they didn't even want him to speak
and they shut they had a whole protest
against him
and they want to get him fired yeah
that's probably a bad idea
he should he should probably be allowed
to speak
um probably yeah i i will say probably
and
because i'm not absolutely definite um
very likely i think
but i'm i won't say that about
absolutely everybody
so for instance um uh let's take what's
his name spencer
richard smith richard spencer who's a
right who's a white nationalist
yes yeah see i have serious qualms about
uh allowing him to speak
um we
universities that is are in a kind of a
bind here
if we let if the universities let
richard spencer speak
he gets a kind of prestige and cachet
so you're worried about legitimizing
yeah a little bit he gets
just by allowing him to speak at a
university
um and then but if we turn him down then
we get branded as being
is censoring him political correctness
and so on
universities can't win
and often right wing right wingers know
we can't win
and often they don't even care whether
they're allowed to speak or not
because they know they're going to win
just by
either speaking or being turned down and
then they go to the press and say we're
being censored
and then they get you know they win some
notoriety for this
anyway i don't think that um
intellectual real intellectual life of
the university is in any way harmed by
so-called political correctness the real
dangers to universities
is completely tangential to this the
real dangers is the commercialization of
research
we haven't talked about that at all and
that's that's a that's a really big deal
and it's an incredibly deep subject then
you probably don't want to go into it
and you have a talk about that right
well you know i
i i used to do a lot of work i i haven't
done much recently but i used to do a
lot of work on this you have one that's
public that people can go to
that people can search on youtube yeah
yeah i can i can i don't
not off the top of my head but i can
find something and we'll put the links
in the description
i'll give you a link yeah but the
commercialization of research is having
a tremendous effect
uh pharmaceuticals i think are just
about the worst
yeah it skews research so health
problems are not tackled by the best
solution
they're tackled by chemical solutions
which might be the best solution
but maybe diet exercise
for depression things like exercise
are at least as effective as the the
best um uh antidepressants
without science but you can't yeah but
you can't make um
you can't patent it and so it's having
an effect on what kind of research is
actually carried out
that is a real worry so if we're
interested in
the truth and not just the truth but
truths that are good for human beings
you know that improves the quality of
our lives
our health for instance then we have to
really really really
worry and get a grip it's just far too
much money
coming in from industry and um
they're they're in fact often they don't
give all that much money
but um they'll they top up like the
government
but we get money from the government
funding
and that's arm's length that there's the
government doesn't interfere with that
they just give
you know the national research council
money and then they distribute it in a
peer-reviewed way to
physics and chemistry and so on but uh
often um
individual researchers will go to will
will apply for money from a
pharmaceutical company so they're
getting a ton of money
from the government and the
pharmaceutical company will often give
them
significant top-ups and it'll change the
direction of the research
and that's having a very bad effect and
we're just getting crap
uh drugs often these days because of it
you're not a fan of the fda do you feel
like that the fda is not so bad the fda
doesn't have enough
i i remember hearing a talk that the
fda's restrictions are too much are too
restrictive because they're limiting the
amount of drugs that can come
into market oh no they're not
restrictive enough
in that sense um drug companies will
complain
that they're slow and restrictive
and so on no we need to we need to
change the fda rules
well the americans need to change them
uh right now
the they they are mandated to license
anything that goes through a clinical
trial
and is is considered effective when
compared with a placebo
that can be incredibly minuscule you
know
and and yet billions of dollars will be
spent on on
on these drugs and if this drug gets
patented
and there's only generics to compete
with it then
they'll pour a ton of money into
advertising
doctors will start prescribing this and
doctors can be
corrupted by their prescription habits
and get money from the
pharmaceuticals yeah
you know about the cheerleaders yeah
that's remarkable
um and uh and these
often uh the a very old generic drug is
much much better than
these new newer drugs uh fewer side
effects
better positive effect incredibly cheap
you know to to produce and so on uh it's
a it's really a tragedy
it's hard to know how to combat it i
think i i think i know how to combat it
in canada
hard to know how to combat it in the
united states because the united states
economy is so structured around
intellectual property rights
i've tried to figure out how much of
american exports to the world
is in the form of ip rights because
whenever you buy anything that's
american
i mean you buy a piece of plastic but
it's got but its value
is in the form of ip rights mostly and
um so what percentage of the economy is
actually
i p rights i don't actually have views
across the board on patents but on drugs
i think it's uh it's a terrible mistake
and we should eliminate patents on drugs
um one of the reasons is
unlike say my new iphone full of patents
yeah but i can tell whether the damn
thing works yeah
you know i just turn it on and it works
or it doesn't work but
in the case of almost every drug there's
no way for
an individual to determine whether he or
she is benefiting from this drug
all you can do is look at it in a very
statistical way and there's an incentive
to produce a drug that works as long as
you take it
true and that's not good uh oh i see
what you mean
yes um treating chronic diseases is
is much better than curing something
with a vaccine
for instance yeah yeah all kinds of
problems like this
um anyway commercialization that's
i think is the real threat to
intellectual life
um and not political correctness which
is really really small potatoes
even in its worst examples
you said that you had some trouble with
jordan peterson's
point of view of truth oh well watching
uh
watching a video that you directed me to
and i'm glad
this was a video a discussion between
him
and sam harris who you also don't
necessarily like uh i have special
problems with harris maybe to talk about
that
later yeah so this was uh
harris invited him on and harris seems
to be
one of these people who doesn't like
political correctness
and thought that jordan peterson might
be good
a nice ally perhaps because he too is
anti-political correctness
and so on but then they got bogged down
on this notion of truth and and as far
as i can tell
peterson is just wacko on the concept of
truth
um i should just explain
when people talk about truth they're not
talking about particular truths
like we can argue whether or not the the
neutrino has mass
okay we don't know what's true and we
don't know what's false and we can argue
about that and produce evidence
this is arguing about the very concept
of truth itself what does it mean for
something to be true
and a normal person normal philosophers
standard philosophers take us
more or less a common sense view about
truth so a sentence
a statement a belief
is true because it corresponds to the
way things are
so the sentence there is a
recording device on the table that's the
sentence
that's a true sentence because there is
in fact
a table a recording device and one is
on top of the other it's a very simple
conception of truth
there are other conceptions some people
say no no
truth has got to be linked to evidence
so the sentence
there is a recording device on the table
is true if and only if there's
some method of gathering
evidence to establish that truth lacking
that evidence it's not true
if you're a realist about truth as i am
then
a sentence could be true even though the
evidence isn't there for it
you shouldn't believe it if you don't
have the evidence that's a different
matter
but truth and evidence are are things
that you can pry apart
so what is peterson's conception truth
as you understand it crazy idea
um that he calls darwinian
and so a sentence is true if it has
survival value
he's thinking of this as a very crude uh
thing um there is there are some
uh philosophical ideas about truth that
are
maybe a little close to that you know
that he might if he knew about them
he could say oh that's i sort of believe
that pragmatism
pragmatism often um identifies truth
with what
is workable detectable
serviceable to life serviceable to life
but it's
more much more sophisticated than mere
crude darwinian survival value um
but you can sort of see some kinship
between
peterson's view and
and pragmatism now the trouble with
peterson's crude view is
there's a ton of stuff we know that's
independent of survival value
in fact may even be true contrary to
survival value
so just think of all the things you know
about quantum field theory
that that wouldn't help you in this in
life's struggle at all you could
if you were in if you're in the jungle
trying to
you know uh like like our distant
ancestors you're not going to
survive thank thank goodness uh based on
your
your knowledge of quantum field theory
you could make out a jordan type case
for a lot of crude simple beliefs
like um trust your color perception to
distinguish
edible things from non-edible things you
know that sort of level
that's fine but to be to to enter into
the realm of sophisticated science which
he certainly wants to
participate in he's got to have an awful
lot more
subtle and sophisticated view of what
he's doing than his simple darwinian
view of truth
you